on est très heureux de vous accueillir
ici dans cette salle euh vous qui
représentez les organisations syndicales
parce que
cette préoccupation de
des questions sociales et de la manière
dont est ressenti dans le groupe public
ferroviaire au sens large au-delà même
de fraté SNCF la solution discontinuité
est une préoccupation qui s'est exprimée
à plusieurs reprises et du reste venant
de la quasi-totalité des groupes de
cette assemblée messieurs je vous
remercie oui c'est messieurs d'ailleurs
et il y a pas de représentants de femmes
à des organisations syndicales
on peut le regretter en tout cas
aujourd'hui je sais que ça aurait pu
être différent si nous en avions fait la
demande explicite je vous remercie donc
de vous être les uns les autres rendus
disponibles comme vous le savez notre
commission d'enquête à deux
angles particuliers le premier consiste
à réfléchir à la question du frais de
ferroviaire comme mode de transport des
marchandises en France et à l'évolution
de sa part modale depuis
[Musique]
1995 qui est à peu près la période sur
laquelle nous conduisons les premières
auditions en tout cas la première
ministre que nous avons auditionné
Anne-Marie Idrac
dégradation qui est constante y compris
avant 2005 2006 et qui vient de loin
puisque on voit que les chiffres de la
part modale s'effondre dès la fin des
années 70 mais dégradation dont certains
ici dans la Commission ont pu estimer
ici et là qu'elle avait pas été freinée
et peut-être même qu'elle avait été
stimulée cette dégradation par la
libéralisation du marché ferroviaire à
marcher qui en tout cas n'avait
peut-être pas été accompagné
suffisamment par des politiques
publiques en face de cette
libéralisation et avec une question Une
difficulté de stratégie publique sur
cette politique du frais de ferroviaire
qui faisait que là où la libéralisation
n'avait pas entamé parfois même avait
permis de reconquérir des parts modales
à l'étranger elle n'avait pas produit
d'effets semblables en France avec une
dégradation jusqu'à une date récente
de la part modale du frais de
ferroviaire et dans un paysage global où
le lien entre la transition écologique
et l'activité du frais de ferroviaire
n'était peut-être pas établie de façon
aussi nette qu'il est désormais
je vous propose puisqu'on est dans pour
le premier vous êtes les premières
personnalités que nous recevons avec ce
format collectif
je pense que c'est un adjectif qui vous
déplairera pas aux uns et aux autres et
donc je vous propose que vous preniez la
parole par organisation syndicale pour
environ 5 minutes chacun on aura
l'occasion ensuite de donner la parole
aux différents collègues qui
souhaiteront s'exprimer et évidemment
alors je vais vous demander de le faire
tout ce collectivement on le fera pas à
chaque prise de parole vous le savez
certains d'entre vous ont déjà participé
à des commissions d'enquêtes où assister
à nos travaux depuis le début de la
semaine dernière vous savez que au
regard des dispositions de l'article 6
de l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires toutes les
personnes qui prennent la parole devant
une commission d'enquête doivent prêter
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité et rien que la vérité je vais
donc vous demander à tous une bonne fois
pour toute et collectivement de lever la
main droite et de dire de façon
distincte je le jure
je vais donc donner la parole à une
première organisation syndicale alors
sans que ça ça ait de sens quelconque
dans l'appréhension que je peux avoir de
ces sujets on va commencer par cette
partie là peut-être de notre demi-cercle
et donc par la CGT cheminot
merci monsieur le Président alors pour
ce qui concerne la procédure européenne
la CGT considère qu'elle est hypocrite
injuste et contre-productive hypocrite
parce que d'abord c'est un secret de
polichinelle j'ai eu personnellement des
discussions avec le président Pepi en
2018 sur le sujet dans lequel il
m'assurait du gouverne du soutien du
gouvernement et du fait que de toute
façon nous n'aurions pas à rendre le
compte sur le modèle choisi nous avons
des échos de couloir je vais appeler ça
comme ça puisque ce sont nos syndiqués
dont vous comprendrez qu'on ne souhaite
pas spécialement rendre compte de leur
nom qui nous ont alerté sur les
discussions autour de la discontinuité
depuis environ deux ans
donc aujourd'hui
nous considérons que le processus qui
est lancé est un faux processus
puisqu'il compris d'ailleurs l'histoire
du compromis signifie que la procédure
d'instruction n'a aucune valeur puisque
les conclusions sont écrites déjà à
l'avance
donc nous considérons que c'est une
procédure hypocrite injuste parce que
les aides sont la conséquence de la
restructuration du Fret SNCF et là je
m'adresse à ceux qui ne connaissent pas
bien forcément le système ferroviaire
avant 2003 le transport de marchandises
ferroviaire est totalement intégré voire
même fusionner à l'intérieur de la
production de la SNCF il est centralisé
planifié monopoliste il s'auto contrôle
notamment en termes de règles de
sécurité et de formation du personnel et
il n'a même pas de bilan financier
propre
considérer qu'on va passer de cette
situation fusionnelle à une entité
autonome concurrentielle en 4 ans avec
un milliard et demi d'eau de recapiter
les actions c'est une vaste plaisanterie
pour comparer même si c'est
difficilement comparable l'Allemagne
c'est 66 milliards de Deutsch Mark en 93
16 milliards de Deutsch Mark en 90 en 96
17 milliards de Deutschmark en 2000 et
un plan sur 10 ans pour transformer son
marché
à cela s'ajoute pour nous le mensonge
originel tout va se développer alors que
l'on sait très bien que l'une des
activités du transport ferroviaire à
savoir le wagon isolé est une activité
de service public et qu'il va falloir
entre guillemets la purger puisqu'elle
ne répondra pas au caractéristiques de
la concurrence le principe du wagon
isolé c'est qu'il faut qu'il soit
assemblé et qu'on ne peut pas isoler
justement les les marchés les uns des
autres à partir du moment où tout
soumettez tout à la concurrence
évidemment le transport d'un wagon isolé
ça n'est absolument pas rentable et ça
ne peut pas l'être dans ce dans ce
système là donc à partir de 2003 se met
en place un certain nombre de plans
successifs qui vise à purger le marché
et donc à liquider d'une certaine
manière le wagon isolé tel qu'il
existait les concurrents d'ailleurs ce
sont tous construits sur les trains
entiers sur les transports combinés
puisqu'il évidemment il n'allait pas
mettre en place ni l'infrastructure ni
les moyens humains nécessaires à la au
développement du wagon isolé
donc il faut liquider la moitié du
trafic de la SNCF de l'époque 10 000
emplois la desserte de 5000 PME et
évidemment ça ça ne se fait pas en
l'annonçant de manière publique dans la
population et donc se met en place le
système totalement
mensonger de l'époque à savoir on va y
aller par petite touche on va lancer des
plans de relance qui sont en fait des
plans de transformation de l'appareil
productif
ayant un objectif ultime se conformer au
marché donc purger le marché la CGT
dénonçait la casse mais le gouvernement
ne voulait pas assumer cette finalité
donc il a maquillé la liquidation par
étage se faisant il a validé sa il a
fait valider sa première étape de
réorganisation par l'Union européenne
alors qu'il aurait dû présenter
l'ensemble des étapes de son plan mais
évidemment pour ça il fallait assumer le
fait qu'il fallait liquider la moitié du
trafic je note au passage qu'un rapport
sénatorial on peut pas dire que les
choses ne sont pas connues un rapport
sénatorial de 2009 explicitait le fait
que 50% des trafics de la SNCF n'étaient
pas rentable et qu'avec le système
d'augmentation des péages 20%
supplémentaires allaient passer sous la
barre donc on savait très bien que le
système de service public antérieur
devrait être adapté je dirais entre
guillemets dans le sang et donc que ça
allait produire
comme je le disais la purge du marché à
partir de ce moment là nous considé rons
que le premier plan de restructuration
qui a été validé par l'Union européenne
est évidemment notoirement sous-évalué
et c'est ce qui amène à considérer qu'il
y a eu des aides abusives par la suite
puisqu'effectivement ce premier plan
prévoit qu'il n'y ait plus d'aide
ensuite pendant 10 ans
en fait il faut considérer que les 15
ans de restructuration ne sont qu'un
seul et même plan et donc à ce titre il
était éligible aux règles de validation
par l'Union européenne mais
utile fallu le développer comme ça et
nous considérons qu'encore aujourd'hui
l'État français peut parfaitement
développer le l'argumentation comme ça
quelques arguments supplémentaires sur
cette ce caractère injuste d'abord le
frais il faudrait vraiment faire un
travail économique sur le sur la
situation du fraté SNCF parce que il lui
a été attribué des déficits
d'exploitation mais par exemple les
sessions d'actifs qui étaient ces actifs
mais qui à l'époque était fusionné dans
l'ensemble de la SNCF ces produits de
cession d'actifs eux n'ont pas été
attribués aux fraises SNCF donc quand on
attribue que les déficits évidemment au
bout d'un moment ça pose un souci dans
les actifs il y a eu les locomotives et
les wagons je crois que vous avez déjà
eu l'occasion d'en parler sur les
sessions hermiva et akem mais il y a eu
aussi beaucoup beaucoup de terrains
puisque la SNCF est un énorme
propriétaire foncier et que le Fret SNCF
était un énorme pourvoyeur de libération
d'hectares vendus et pour ce qui
concerne ma région par exemple tout le
nouveau quartier de Lyon est l'ancien
triage de Lyon Perrache marchandise je
pense que ça session n'a jamais été
attribué à Fret SNCF
dernier point ce plan il est
contre-productif d'abord parce que
l'abandon de 20 à 30% des trafics mais
ça déjà été dit par d'autres risque de
ne pas être repris pour le Perpignan
Rungis l'appel à manifestation d'intérêt
malgré son contenu qui précisait que
l'État donnerait autant d'aide que
nécessaire c'était spécifié comme ça n'a
fait l'objet que de deux candidatures
dont une était considéré comme non
viable parce que une entreprise trop
petite et la SNCF donc on peut
considérer que il y a peu de chances que
d'autres se positionnent sauf évidemment
à augmenter encore le niveau d'être
public ce qui est paradoxal pour les
libéraux c'est que
à la fin il donne plus d'argent que nous
n'aurions pu le faire nous-même
l'abandon des transports enfin
j'entendais la ministre précédent qui
faisait pas d'inquiétude seuls les
transports les trains complets seront
abandonnés justement ce sont les trains
les plus rentables parce que ce sont les
trains qui nécessitent le moins
d'activités humaines et et le moins
d'investissement et de d'infrastructures
donc on va céder les bijoux de famille
c'est quand même une problématique de
notre point de vue la privatisation est
l'objectif réel de ce projet et nous
nous tenons à dire qu'il n'y a rien de
discontinue là-dedans c'est totalement
la continuité des plans successifs qui
se sont qui se sont succédés ces
dernières années donc une vraie
discontinuité ce serait de changer de de
stratégie et évidemment je termine
là-dessus nous ne voyons là dedans
aucune relance et aucune élément aucun
élément d'aucune sorte qui nous permet
de dire que l'objectif de 25% de par
modal ou doublement de la part modale
selon les selon les époques en 2030 sera
ne serait-ce qu'un projet
je vous remercie
les 25% c'est l'objectif dans les années
2000 effectivement
et donc l'une ça et ferroviaire merci
monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés vous ne recevez
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de l'enquête
sur la libéralisation du frais de
ferroviaire et ses conséquences pour
l'avenir cette commission d'enquête a
été créée à la suite de l'annonce par le
gouvernement du projet de
restructuration de fret SNCF en lien
avec la décision de la Commission
européenne d'engager une procédure
d'examen sur les conditions de
financement de l'activité de fret sur la
période de 2007 à 2019
cette procédure d'examen a suscité de
vivre préoccupation chez les cheminots
et les industriels de la filière quant
aux conséquences négatives qui
pourraient en découler sur l'activité
historique de La SNCF vous l'avez
rappelé dans l'expression des motifs de
résolution pour créer cette commission
d'enquête SNCF jouent encore un rôle
essentiel dans le développement du frais
de ferroviaire en France les conclusions
de l'enquête de la Commission européenne
pourrait avoir des répercussions
significatives sur Fret SNCF tout
d'abord si l'État est reconnu coupable
d'avoir accordé des aides illégales cela
pourrait entraîner des sanctions
financières importantes pour fêter SNCF
cela pourrait affaiblir davantage sa
situation financière déjà précaire et
restreindre ses capacités à investir
dans le développement de ces
infrastructures et de ses services un
autre problème désormais que cette
enquête va également affecter la
réputation de fret SNCF
être impliqué dans une affaire dédit
légale va tenir ternir son image de
marque et réduire la confiance des
clients et des partenaires commerciaux
présents et futurs cela entraînera deux
facto une diminution du volume
d'affaires et une perte de contrat
compromettant ainsi sa capacité à rester
compétitive sur le marché avouez que si
on voulait tuer l'activité Fred de la
SNCF compte ce serait pas pris autrement
du côté de l'UNSA ferroviaire nous
tâchons de jouer dorénavant notre rôle
d'amortisseur social vis-à-vis des
agents qui vont perdre leurs emplois
leur lieu d'affectation leurs équipes
leurs collègues leur métier leurs
espoirs en avenir meilleur pour
l'activité à laquelle ils ont voué toute
leur carrière au prix parfois de
sacrifices aux dépens de leur vie
personnelle et familiale mais quand on
voit les difficultés quotidiennes dans
l'exercice du dialogue social c'est
animé d'une colère froide que nous
assistons à des réunions d'instance
formatées dans lesquelles nous
n'apprenons rien et sur lesquels nous ne
pouvons pas agir
les conséquences de la libéralisation du
frais de ferroviaire la fragmentation du
marché l'ouverture du marché à la
concurrence en 2006 a entraîné une
fragmentation du secteur avec l'arrivée
de plusieurs opérateurs privés cela
conduit à une concurrence accrue et à
une baisse des tarifs ce qui a pu
sembler avantageux pour certains mais
également entraîner une diminution de la
rentabilité de l'entreprise historique
la diminution de la qualité de service
la libéralisation a également entraîné
une réorganisation du mode de gestion de
la SNCF en activité toute différente
comptablement parlant entraînant la fin
de la péréquation économique et une
hausse évidente des coûts matériels et
humains ce qui engendra également très
vite une baisse de la qualité de service
dans le frais de ferroviaire et dans le
ferroviaire tout entière exemple si les
locomotives et leurs agents de conduite
sont dédiés aux activités ils ne peuvent
plus être mutualisés leurs moyens en cas
de défaillance matérielle et humaine les
opérateurs privés ont souvent des
ressources plus limitées en engin et en
personnel ils ont régulièrement des
difficultés à assurer un service fiable
et régulier cela affecte le transport de
marchandises ferroviaire car les
entreprises se tournent vers leur
routier pour plus de régularité
régularité au détriment d'une logique de
développement durable
la réduction des investissements avec
l'arrivée de la concurrence l'entreprise
historique était confrontée à une baisse
logique de ces parts de marché et de la
rentabilité de celle-ci qui ont subsisté
cela entraîna une réduction massive des
investissements de RF et SNCF infras sur
les infrastructures ferroviaires depuis
2005 suppression de faisceau de triage
de votre service dans le multiple gars
d'embranchement particulier de
modernisation des installations
terminales en bronchées les attelages
automatiques etc Cela a produit un effet
domino sur la capacité et l'efficacité
du réseau et si on sont peu fiables
risque de disparition des petites lignes
la libéralisation est également accrue
le risque de disparition des petites
lignes ferroviaires qui ont parfois la
seule voie de passage pour du frais de
ferroviaire elles étaient moins
rentables pour les opérateurs privés
avec au final des conséquences négatives
sur l'accessibilité des régions plus
isolées sur le transport de marchandises
dans les zones peu des services
l'échec de la mise en concurrence les
bénéfices attendus d'une libéralisation
ne sont pas arrivées alors que la mise
en concurrence devait permettre plus
d'offres plus de services plus
d'innovation cela n'a pas fonctionné le
constat est clair tous les opérateurs
ferroviaires sont en difficulté alors
pourquoi cet échec parce que libéralisée
un marché en décroissance est une
aberration si elle n'est pas accompagnée
les soi-disant vertus de la concurrence
ne sont effectives que dans un marché en
développement ainsi les offres
pourraient se diversifier et répondre
aux besoins des clients innover et créer
d'autres marchés les chèques d'une
ouverture du marché dans une période de
décroissance était prévisible car seuls
les tarifs étaient en jeu l'ensemble des
opérateurs en ont subi les conséquences
libéralisées l'une safervira toujours
été contre mais sans accompagnement
c'est de toute façon l'échec assuré il
aura fallu et il faudra au-delà des
promesses et objectifs futures s'assurer
de la croissance du marché par des
décisions politiques fortes en faveur du
transport ferroviaire de marchandises je
vous remercie pour votre attention
merci Monsieur le doc donc la parole est
à sud-ail
c'est ça merci bonjour à toutes et à
tous donc une prise de parole au nom de
la fédération SUD Rail
en 1827 la première ligne de chemin de
fer ne transporte pas des voyageurs mais
des marchandises entre Saint-Étienne et
andrezieux en 1882 la France possède la
plus forte densité du chemin de fer au
monde avec 25000 km de voies en 1950 et
2/3 des marchandises sont transportés
par le rail et c'est le transport de
marchandises qui fait vivre la SNCF
à partir des années 70-80 nous assistons
au déclin du frais de ferroviaire qui
n'est pas un signe de modernité
économique dans un pays en 1984 le
ferrovert ne représentea plus que 30% du
transport de marchandises la baisse est
brutale ce chiffre face à 20% en 1990
17% en 2000 après l'échec du plan Véron
et nous sommes à 10% environ
actuellement en parallèle les effectifs
des cheminottes et des cheminots
rattachés aux Fret SNCF n'ont fait que
diminuer depuis 2009 ce sont 63% des
emplois qui est aussi ont été supprimés
et si certains certaines pensaient que
l'ouverture à la concurrence allait
permettre la revitalisation selon les
termes de la Commission du Fred
ferroviaire c'est bien à son naufrage
auquel nous avons assisté les opérateurs
privés se sont rués sur les parties les
plus potentiellement rentables du frais
de ferroviaire à savoir les trains
entiers
ils ont écrémé les meilleures trafics
les auteurs ainsi à la SNCF sont ancrés
de nouveau et imposant à celle-ci qui ne
peut plus procéder à une péréquation
entre trafic rentable et trafic
déficitaire d'abandonner à peu près
totalement le trafic par wagon isolé
Fred SNCF et un des opérateurs
historiques dont la position sur le
territoire c'est le plus dégradé
le pourcentage de marchandises
transportés par rail désormais en France
le plus fait parmi tous les pays de
l'Union européenne comparable et qu'un
gouvernement responsable ne serait
l'accepter gouverner c'est prévoir
dit-on or avec le projet qui nous est
présenté par le gouvernement et la
Direction SNCF l'effacement au cours du
frais de ferroviaire va se poursuivre
secteur public et privé confondu la
fédération SUD Rail souhaite se saisir
de cette commission d'enquête pour
prolonger la prise de conscience
collective du caractère vital du défi
climatique de l'importance de la
stratégie du rail et singulièrement du
frais de ferroviaire
les menaces affichées par la Commission
européenne que le gouvernement français
la Direction SNCF ont décidé d'en
compagnie sans aucune opposition soit un
coût porté à l'environnement et une
décision contraire aux orientations de
la politique des transports de l'Europe
de réduire les émissions nettes de gaz à
effet de serre d'au moins 55% d'ici à
2030 par rapport au niveau de 1990
un train fret représente 35 points
lourds le rail émet 14 fois moins de CO2
entraîne 8 fois moins de pollution d'air
et consomme 6 fois moins d'énergie
aujourd'hui nous nous considérons en
légitime défense face à la liquidation
de Fred SNCF ou nouvelle coupe sur les
emplois les trafics et les moyens de
production envisagés par le plan de
discontinuité nous n'acceptons pas ces
traités européens qui parce qu'ils ne
vise qu'à installer la concurrence
contribue à détruire l'environnement
c'est notre devoir en tant que citoyen
c'est un autre combat syndical que nous
mènerons jusqu'au bout comme en 2020
lors de la crise liée au coronavirus ou
l'Union européenne a suspendu ses règles
de discipline budgétaire face aux
conséquences économiques et sociales
maintenant la France doit exiger la
sortie des marchés de la concurrence du
frais de ferroviaire face à l'urgence
climatique nous devons sortir de cette
position qui consiste à préserver le
marché c'est à dire la concurrence sur
ce secteur essentiel tout en prétendant
prétendant limiter les effets pervers
ce dogme n'est pas efficace et anti
transition écologique la situation de
Fred SNCF ne relève pas d'un traitement
de faveur particulier de la veut même de
la Cour européenne nombre d'opérateurs
historiques de fret reçoivent des aides
subventions de la part des gouvernements
pour les maintenir sur les rails
nous sommes une fois de plus en face
d'une situation où le gouvernement
français a pris le risque de mettre en
danger le la survie d'une entreprise
publique en refusant la nécessité de
réformer profondément sa politique et en
laissant filer une spirale incontrôlée
nous savons déjà que les filiales de
droit privé imaginées par la Direction
SNCF ne trouveront pas de viabilité
économique et sociale nous pouvons
également affirmer que le lancement de
plan de discontinuité déstabilise déjà
le secteur le début de report modal
inversé a commencé des marchandises sont
retournés déjà sur la route ces
dernières semaines de trafic qui se
trouve soit dans la liste des 23 ont été
abandonnés ont été arrêtés Barcelone
bétonbourg et Valenton 7 une ligne rouge
affichée par le ministre délégué chargé
des transports de France a déjà été
franchi
la liquidation de fret SNCF va se
traduire par toujours plus de gains de
productivité et malgré les affirmations
de Monsieur Beaune il y aura bien des
suppressions d'emplois à Fret SNCF dans
le ferroviaire par exemple ce sont des
résidences traction entités essentielles
pour maintenir des organisations de
travail efficaces qui risquent d'être
rayés de la carte on parle la radio
ballast de Chalon de Nîmes de Perpignan
en tant que représentant et
représentante du personnel nous ne
pouvons pas passer sous silence les
conséquences comme la souffrance au
travail que va induire cette énième
réorganisation nous sommes proches d'un
nouveau syndrome France Télécom à Fret
SNCF la direction d'entreprise parle
d'un choc très fort pour l'ensemble des
salariés et un sentiment de profonde
injustice et ressenti par des milliers
de collègues qui ont fait leur maximum
pour préserver Fred SNCF depuis plus de
15 ans ce plan de discontinuité prescrit
encore et toujours plus de productivité
à exiger des cheminots et des cheminotes
encourage à poursuivre la maltraitance
sociale ce qui ne permettra pas de
renforcer la cohésion du corps social
cheminot pourtant indispensable dans les
enjeux vitaux qui nous attendent
nous n'avons pas encore touché
définitivement le fond il a encore temps
d'entamer un bouleversement des
fondament des fondements de notre
économie de mode de vie mettons un peu
de côté la libéralisation du frais de
ferroviaire et imaginons une approche
coordonnée entre la politique
industrielle la politique des transports
et le développement des territoires qui
n'a jamais existé dans notre pays les
objectifs fixés supposent que les
transports soient fortement impliqués
dans la planification démocratique
d'autant que ceux-ci exigent des
investissements le plus souvent lourd et
coûteux qui engagent l'avenir et qui
façonne pour longtemps la vie économique
sociale et culturelle d'un pays il faut
sortir de cette vision qui cantonne le
frotte ferroviaire au seul rôle de
support de certaines activités de
production il faut rompre avec la
logique actuelle du système de transport
et de cette vision qui donne une part
toujours croissante et de plus en plus
monopolistique aux fraises routier
le transport de fret est une industrie
territoriale qui doit d'abord tenir
compte de la nature géographique des
flux avant de poser comme préalable et
contraintes techniques et
opérationnelles la SNCF en tant
qu'entreprise intégrée et la seule à
avoir les capacités fédératrices au
niveau des territoires qui sont
nécessaires pour massifier les trafics
pérenniser et renouveler leur
ferroviaire l'enjeu de taille puisqu'il
consiste à sauvegarder d'abord à
développer ensuite un bien public
indispensable à une politique des
transports radicalement nouvelle qui
répondent aux besoins des populations
garantissent des conditions sociales
correctes aux salariés du secteur des
transports et participent au maintien ou
à l'instauration d'une qualité de vie
satisfaisante aussi bien localement que
globalement oui il faut réaménager dans
notre pays notre fraise ferroviaire qui
a été un échec français il y a une
vingtaine d'années et il faut le
développer voilà les mots prononcés par
le Président de la République Emmanuel
Macron lors de la campagne
présidentielle en avril 2022 le constat
est juste si ce n'est que la destruction
dure depuis plus d'une vingtaine
d'années et que le gouvernement
successifs s l'ont tous entretenu à coup
de plan fret et d'ouverture à la
concurrence pour l'avenir de la planète
il faut rompre avec ces politiques
merci merci ça a été un peu plus long
que vous ceux qui vous ont précédé donc
on en tiendra compte dans les questions
qu'on adressera donc la CFDT merci
monsieur le Président peut-être juste
avant de peut-être de remplir dans le
moment d'échanges de questions souligner
peut-être quelques points saillants
qu'on souhaite mettre en exerg au niveau
de la CFDT premièrement qu'on souhaite
déjà souligner c'est un paradoxe voilà
clairement à notre sens aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans un moment dans un dans une
des politiques publiques qui peuvent qui
sont paradoxales voire même
contradictoire puisque d'un côté nous
avons effectivement l'obligation de
transition écologique l'urgence
climatique qui se rappelle à nous je
pense qu'effectivement on a encore tous
des exemples en tête et que l'été qu'on
vient de passer et on voit effectivement
des engagements des stratégies des
objectifs qui sont de plus en plus forts
que ça soit au niveau de l'Union
européenne mais également de la France
on voit notamment sur la stratégie bas
carbone les objectifs qui ont été
revisités par le Conseil national à la
transition écologique récemment et de
l'autre côté on voit que la France est à
la traîne au niveau de l'Europe le
constat qu'on peut poser c'est en termes
de report modal on est dans les
lanternes rouges mais en tout cas on est
la traîne par rapport à d'autres pays
donc vraiment
on veut souligner ce paradoxe cette
contradiction contradiction qui amène
quand même à ne pas comprendre ce choix
parce qu'effectivement le choix de la
discontinuité à notre sens va un effet
de souffle très fort non seulement sur
les parateurs publics mais aussi sur
tout le secteur et précipiter accentuer
en tout cas
détériorer le report modal qui est en
cours alors qu'on voit qu'aujourd'hui
même dans les scénarios les plus
optimistes qui peuvent être posés je
vais essayer de 2030 sont déjà très
difficilement atteignables donc ça c'est
le premier point que je souhaite
souligner deuxième point ce que je
souhaite également mettre en exerce une
conviction qui nous anime à la CFDT
cheminot c'est que cette discontinuité
c'est le choix du pire
c'est le plus mauvais choix pour la
transition écologique effectivement que
je viens de détailler le plus mauvais
choix pour les salariés que nous
représentons le plus mauvais choix aussi
pour l'opérateur public mais aussi tous
le secteur et on pourrait revenir si
vous le souhaitez et également pour les
territoires et on pourrait aussi le
détailler si vous le souhaitez parce
qu'on a un moment où effectivement on
mise sur une stratégie de
l'industrialisation de la France là
encore c'est extrêmement paradoxal de
venir courir un risque de ne plus
irriguer correctement les territoires en
matière de transport troisième point que
je souhaite souligner entre points
interruptif c'est une réalité
c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
plus d'assurance que ce scénario de la
discontinuité
à une chance de voler qu'il n'en avait
en 2018 alors c'est pas qu'on remet en
cause on n'est pas là pour ça la parole
la parole des politiques ou la parole de
Commission européenne se compose juste
c'est un constat qui nous paraît comme à
souligner c'est qu'en 2018 le scénario
tel qu'il était posé pour la nouveau
pack perroviaire était sécurisé au
niveau de Bruxelles vraisemblablement
la question qu'on pose c'est que
aujourd'hui quelle confiance peut-on
avoir en la parole de la Commission
européenne alors qu'on se retrouve
finalement dans un moment très très
similaire cette question à notre sens
doit être posée quatrième point que je
souhaite également mettre en avant c'est
une réalité réalité qu'aujourd'hui quand
on parle de Fred ferroviaire on voit
souvent par un prisme qui est notre sens
n'est pas le bon prisme d'entrée
c'est-à-dire l'angle de ce que ça coûte
mais on oublie souvent aussi l'angle de
ce que fait rapporte à la collectivité
aujourd'hui on a effectivement ces 5
milliards qui sont un petit peu ancré
dans le paysage avec ses griefs de la
Commission européenne qui superposent
dans la différents montants financiers
qui amènent à ces 5 milliard quatre mais
ce qu'on oublie c'est que sur une même
période depuis 2008 fret il va rapport
récent qui a été publié au niveau du
cs:- fret a dégagé 10 milliards étaient
positives
et là il y a aussi effectivement un
enjeu ou fret et un outil qui a
énormément est bon pour la collectivité
et bon pour le pays et on se rappelle
quand même aussi un point également que
je peux pas mettre souligner c'est le
rôle comme essentiel qu'à jouer frette
SNCF ainsi que les autres opérateurs de
fret au sens large au moment de la crise
sanitaire notamment au premier
confinement en assurant quand même un
nombre important de transport et de
trafiqué essentiel pour la nation enfin
dernier dernier point que je souhaite
aussi évoqué dans ses propos
introductifs c'est
là aussi la responsabilité des choix qui
ont été faits et ça a été évoqué par le
collègue de la CGT sur notamment les
sessions d'actifs aujourd'hui on est
devant un dilemme une question qui est
d'ordre financière alors que quand on
regarde un petit peu et il y a pas
besoin de remonter le temps jusqu'au 19e
siècle pour ça on voit que on a des
sessions d'actifs qui sont somme toute
assez récentes je pense notamment à qui
aime herméva ou des sessions
immobilières ou le choix a été fait de
que ces sessions qui étaient quand même
sur des actifs de traité SNCF les
l'argent qui a été effectivement
rapporté sur ces ventes le choix qui a
été fait c'est le consolider au niveau
de du groupe SNCF donc c'est somme au
contribué au déserts du groupe alors que
logiquement elles ouvraient pu elles
auraient dû et c'est des choix
d'ailleurs que la CDT cheminot a
contesté que ça soit au niveau au niveau
de la SNCF au delà en disant à notre
sens là on s'égare on sait très bien
qu'il y a une dette ou des
investissements qui sont nécessaires
pour fret et il est logique que ces
fonds viennent financer puisque
finalement et pour finir on va quand
même que les griefs aujourd'hui qui sont
fait Alfred c'est quoi c'est finalement
de cette dit que Fred se retrouve dans
un moment où il était pendant une
période seule opérateur et en fait il y
avait un désengagement de la puissance
publique qui l'obligeait à
s'autofinancer ou alors on a arrêté
l'activité et aujourd'hui finalement
tous paradoxe c'est qu'on vient
reprocher à fret d'avoir continué
au service de la France d'art continuer
à mener une politique de transport
public alors que il y avait un
désengagement quand même très important
de l'État sur lequel aussi on pourra
revenir voilà je fais pas plus loin à
propos intrusif on s'y habite dans notre
disposition pour pour répondre aux
questions
bien vous le savez puisque certains
d'entre vous soient ont suivi en direct
soit sur grand écran ou petit écran ces
auditions donc on commence par des
questions du président puis du
rapporteur et ensuite des différents
collègues qui sont présents et qui sont
ici nombreux moi j'ai quatre questions
ça tombe bien chacune pour une
organisation syndicale d'abord pour le
secrétaire général de la CGT cheminot
monsieur Brun
si vous avez parlé vous êtes le premier
à l'avoir fait même si on a évoqué ces
produits de cession d'actifs à plusieurs
reprises
la session d'armeva et d'acquiem et le
fait que le procès est produite de
cession n'avait pas été dirigé vers Fret
SNCF j'imagine qu'ils l'ont été vers
SNCF réseau
mais ce que vous pouvez simplement nous
le confirmer puisque ce ne serait pas ce
ne serait pas un cas isolé puisque par
exemple pour garer connexion sur les
grandes gares les profits qui sont
dégagés ne restent pas à garer connexion
ils vont avoir un réseau mais je voulais
simplement avoir cette confirmation sur
l'endroit vers où c'est produit de
cession d'actifs ont été dirigés au sein
du groupe public ferroviaire
une question pour l'INSA pour Monsieur
le doc qui s'est exprimé tout à l'heure
vous allez parler de du paradoxe à
libéralisé dans un marché qui était en
attrition et qu'il était votre voisin a
dit ensuite avec beaucoup de précision
depuis de très longues décennies
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
puisque les cheminots vous êtes
sont à l'écoute des cheminots qui sont
en contact des clients est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment que on est aujourd'hui
dans un marché en développement beaucoup
des personnes qui se sont exprimées ici
quel que soit leur statut leurs opinions
politiques du reste
nous ont dit qu'elles avaient constaté
ces dernières années et en fait de façon
relativement récente
soit à la faveur du lien plus
systématique entre la transition
écologique et le frais de ferroviaire
soit à la faveur d'une forme de prise de
conscience au moment de la covid-19 du
caractère stratégique de cette activité
que quelque chose s'était passé et que
dans le redressement des résultats de
fêter SNCF pour la première fois avec
une marge opérationnelle positive en
2021 et 2022 depuis des décennies en
tout cas depuis l'évolution que certains
d'entre vous ont évoqué en 2003
dans cette évolution là dans ce
redressement et dans le redressement
global du secteur qu'on voit à travers
la part modale il y avait finalement la
traduction aussi au-delà des mesures
gouvernementales d'une envie de train
chez des chargeurs qui étaient moins
présentes il y a quelques années alors
est-ce que vous pourriez donc ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on a entendu ici je
crois pas déformer les propos de
certaines des personnes qui ont été
auditionnées est-ce que vous le
ressentez ce que vous avez des retours
tels de la part de vos adhérents et des
cheminots que vous représentez
pour le secrétaire général de SUD Rail
monsieur trocas qui s'est exprimé
vous êtes revenu
sur l'histoire de cette dégradation de
la part modale c'est une question qu'on
a posé à presque tout le monde a presque
tous ceux qui sont intervenus ici parce
que finalement dans notre commission il
y a ce sujet de la discontinuité et
globalement de la libéralisation donc
qui concerne Fret SNCF confronté à la
concurrence mais il y a aussi le sujet
de l'effondrement de la part modale et
de la manière dont on le comprend et
comme vous l'avez évoqué et que vous
avez évoqué ce fait qui venait de très
loin du reste c'est un effondrement qui
s'est produit dans d'autres pays
européens pas seulement en France mais
qui a été enrayé ailleurs depuis le
début des années 2000 avec les mêmes
politiques d'ouverture à la concurrence
comment en tout cas quand on regarde ce
qui se passe en Allemagne en Suisse en
Autriche et en Belgique on voit qu'on
n'est pas du tout sur la même part
modèle comment expliquer vous que on ait
eu cet effondrement de la part du frais
de ferroviaire alors qu'on était en
situation monopolistique dans les années
80-90
et que qu'est-ce qu'il aurait fallu
selon vous je suis conscient que ça vous
amène à les uns les autres à vous
projeter dans un modèle qui vous paraît
en soi pernicieux mais qu'est-ce qu'il
aurait fallu selon vous pour que Fred
SNCF puisse mieux résister à l'ouverture
à la concurrence
et plus globalement parce que le sujet
de Fred SNCF c'est un sujet mais le vrai
sujet de politique publique c'est le
sujet de la part modale du frais de
ferroviaire pour que la part modale du
frais de ferroviaire
remonte en France qu'est-ce qu'il aurait
fallu faire dans ces années 2000 qui n'a
pas été fait visiblement
selon vous enfin une question pour la
CFDT alors
petite juste une petite remarque mais je
l'ai fait souvent certains diront trop
souvent mais sur
le statut et la différence entre ce qui
s'est passé en 2002 entre 2018 et 2020
et la discontinuité actuelle tout le
sujet c'est endroit une société
peut-elle être tenue responsable des
engagements d'une société qu'il a
précédé
et il est indiscutable que du point de
vue du droit
les pics fêtaient SNCF avaient bien
comme héritier la SA
SNCF fret c'est indiscutable c'est
exactement les mêmes activités
exactement les mêmes actifs et donc on
peut pas comparer cela avec ce qu'essaye
de construire la France voilà compris
les uns les autres et positions des uns
des autres
qu'il est justement de pouvoir dire en
droit que ça n'est pas la même
entreprise ce qui fait que une
éventuelle condamnation sur les 5
milliards 3
ne te retombera pas sur le dos de
l'entreprise qui arrivera parce qu'elle
sera suffisamment différente pour qu'en
droit européen on considère que ça n'est
pas la même entreprise alors qu'en droit
en 2018 2020 la transformation et ça a
fait que c'était la même entreprise et
c'est justement pour ça que l'action
publique a été ouverte s'il y avait eu
discontinuité il n'y aurait sans doute
pas cette action publique qu'on vit
aujourd'hui donc la question de question
l'une très précise vous allez évoquer le
rapport sur les externalités positives
on a eu un aparté avec Monsieur
administrateur ça doit être le rapport
cécafi j'imagine mais je voulais juste
en avoir la confirmation et sur l'effet
de souffle négatif c'est un petit peu
l'envers de la question que j'ai posée à
Monsieur le doc
je lui ai posé une question sur l'envie
de train je vais poser une question sur
ce que vous entendez vous de la part de
vos adhérents sur la crainte des
chargeurs
vis-à-vis de cette solution
discontinuité de ceux qui travaillent
avec Fred SNCF et qui ont recours à ces
flux
c'est 23 flux complets avec des moyens
dédiés et réguliers est-ce que c'est
exactement ça c'est 23 flux
qu'est-ce que vous entendez de cette
inquiétude et en particulier dans quel
secteur et sur quel flux ça nous
intéresserait d'avoir ces réponses voilà
j'ai déjà été un peu long donc je donne
tout de suite la parole puisque c'était
dans cet ordre là à Monsieur secrétaire
général Laurent brun oui pour ce qui est
des sessions d'hermévale d'akhem bon
d'abord une aparté pour dire que elles
ont elles ont été vendues du point de
vue purement capitalistique puisque
c'est des fonds de pension qu'ils ont
rachetés donc il y a aucune stratégie
industrielle derrière et c'était une de
nos critiques à l'époque les montants
des ventes qui doivent être d'environ
on est en quelle année exactement au
moment où je me rappelle plus
précisément les deux les deux étapes la
dernière c'était 2022 l'année dernière
et celle d'avant 6 ans
ah oui la fin de la deuxième partie
voilà
[Musique]
donc tout ça alimente la trésorerie
disponible du groupe
je crois que le montant total c'est 4
milliards
et ensuite le groupe
utilise sa trésorerie disponible pour sa
politique une fraction va probablement à
l'infrastructure mais également à
d'autres opérations capitalistiques
comme le rachat de HL aux États-Unis ou
d'autres ou d'autres opérations
capitalistiques qu'on a pu qu'on a pu
mener je vous invite à ne pas oublier la
session des terrains
toute activité confondue évidemment
puisque nous n'avons pas le détail
c'est pareil et une petite partie et le
résultat de vente d'ateliers du matériel
qui ont fermé autre chose comme ça mais
la grosse partie c'est les emprises de
fret SNCF c'est 300 millions d'euros par
an depuis 20 ans
donc c'est une somme colossale qu'il a
aussi va alimenter les comptes les
comptes du groupe on pourrait se dire
quand même que peut-être que quand le
groupe reprend une partie de la dette en
définitive
auprès de qui était la dette quoi moi je
je m'interroge et en tout cas je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui parle les
services de l'État et par les services
de la SNCF sont
doivent pouvoir être instruits pour
engager le bras de fer je crois le
disait monsieur djibari sur le avec la
commission
pour comparaison
là aussi d'investissement enfin de
situation
la
les produits les produits les
investissements dans le domaine de
l'infrastructure en Allemagne par
exemple ce que vous avez évoqué
l'Allemagne c'est trois quarts l'Etat et
les Landers qui apportent les
investissements on parle de 13,6
milliards d'investissements 2022 on doit
être à peu près un peu moins de 6 en
France si je me trompe pas donc on est
sur des des niveaux d'aide
peut-être correctement
comment dirais-je correctement étayé
dans les rapports enfin voilà je
la parole est à l'une ça merci monsieur
le Président alors pour répondre à votre
question c'est un peu délicat puisque
nous ne sommes pas dans l'action
politique mais dans l'action syndicale
mais on peut constater qu'effectivement
le redressement de financier de
l'activité fret vient de plusieurs
éléments notamment un choix politique de
certaines entreprises d'aller vers une
amélioration de leur RSE et notamment de
faire confiance à un transporteur
ferroviaire quand c'est possible plutôt
qu'un transporteur autre plus polluant
comme c'est le cas du routier donc c'est
un des premiers
aspect en sachant que pardon la France
est en retard sur la diminution des gaz
à effet de serre et donc c'était plutôt
une mouvance intéressante qui là pour le
coup semble-t-il va être cassé par les
décisions qui sont en train d'être
prises donc c'est un peu dommage il y a
également un autre aspect qui est
l'augmentation de la productivité
qu'on a demandé aux salariés avec des
réorganisations incessantes et avec
également on peut le dire l'abandon de
certains marchés pour aller vers des
marchés plus rentables et ça c'est plus
regrettable mais c'est aussi une réalité
et c'est pour ça qu'on a vu les
effectifs de fret diminué assez
considérablement même si on ajoute
l'ensemble des effectifs aujourd'hui
dans le fret avec l'ensemble des
salariés du secteur que toute entreprise
confondue et bien on se rend compte que
la part modale en proportion de salariés
qui étaient à l'époque utilisé qui était
que Fret SNCF pour effectuer 18% du
marché aujourd'hui on a 10% toute
entreprise ferroviaire confondues et
bien on a plus que divisé par deux le
nombre de salariés donc ça ça prend acte
d'une d'une très grande productivité une
plus grande productivité et enfin un
dernier point aussi qui permet d'avoir
des éléments financiers favorables c'est
sans doute le fait qu'aujourd'hui encore
Fret SNCF peut
à différents marchés qui viennent
s'imbriquer l'un dans l'autre avec les
wagons isolés et avec les trains
complets donc les petits flux et les
grands flux qui viennent finalement
faire de la péréquation en interne et
qui permettent de d'assurer des gains
même s'il sort certains marchés c'est
plus difficile comme le wagon isolé qui
est moins rentable merci
comme la question que j'avais posée à la
CFDT finalement assez liée à la vôtre
sur les flux je vais leur donner la
parole tout de suite en m'excusant
d'emblée auprès de ce drive puisque vous
avez une question plus générale donc
allez-y
peut-être une réponse en deux temps
parce que si vous nous permettez on
réagir à votre propos sur la distinction
juridique entre la situation de 2019 et
celle actuelle
notre propos était de souligner comme
d'autres
interlocuteurs l'ont fait auprès de vous
le fait qu'il y avait des assurances qui
avaient été donné en 2019
des assurances moi j'étais
administrateur à l'époque de la SNCF il
y a des assurances qui avaient été
données devant le conseil de
surveillance de la SNCF sur le fait que
la solution qui était proposée bien
qu'elle ne corresponde pas une
discontinuité sur le plan juridique
donner suffisamment de garanties du
point de vue de la commission pour que
on arrête la procédure de sanction qui
avait été engagée et les plaintes ayant
été abandonnées par les opérateurs
concurrents de fret SNCF et donc ce que
nous disons aujourd'hui nous ne
contestons pas que le scénario de
discontinuité qui est posé et à des
conséquences juridiques totalement
différentes et donc peut-être plus
protecteur du fait que on ne
attributaire des actions de des sociétés
qui ont et qui ont précédé qui
précéderaient celles qui seraient
d'après ce scénario de discontinuité
néanmoins vous comprenez qu'il y a une
défiance et c'est ce que vous relater
devant cette commission une défiance y
compris des salariés par rapport à des
garanties qui pourraient être donné sur
un scénario de discontinuité qui est un
scénario sur lequel la France serait
proactive c'est à dire qu'en fait on a
aucune assurance aujourd'hui formelle de
la Commission européenne selon
lesquelles ce scénario de discontinuité
suffirait à la Commission européenne et
en tout cas du point de vue des salariés
si vous voulez les engagements passer on
essaie des traces indépendamment de la
distinction de la situation juridique
qui est celle que vous mentionnez et par
ailleurs je dirais que ce scénario de
défiance sentiment de défiance il est
accentué justement par par la réalité de
ce que veut dire un scénario de
discontinuité comme vous le soulignez
c'est à dire que n'étant pas tributaire
de ce qui était la société
SNCF mobilité avant 2019 on ne pourra
appliquer l'article de la loi devenu
dans le code des transports le l
2101-1-2 à savoir que toute filiale crée
par le groupe public dans le périmètre
existant au 31 décembre 2019 emporte un
certain nombre de continuité de droits
pour les salariés donc ce que vous dites
c'est que le scénario de discontinuité
dans la mesure où on n'est pas
héritier de ce qui s'est passé
auparavant ne permettrait pas
d'appliquer la continuité du cas social
tel qu'il a été prévu par la loi et donc
ça accentuera ce sentiment de défiance
et quand on parle de développement du
frais de ferroviaire ou en tout cas du
maintien des trafics et ça fera la
transition avec la réponse que va vous
apporter Pascal couturier
on ne le fera pas sans les salariés il
faut se rendre compte que la transition
écologique qui se base dans le domaine
des transports en partie sur du report
moda et pour le pour le pour le
transport de marchandises dans le les
prévisions les projections du
secrétariat la planification écologique
c'est quand même 4 millions de tonnes de
CO2 sur les 19 millions d'économies
qu'on doit viser en 2030 le report modal
ça suppose en fait que les salariés
restent voir qu'on en recrute
aujourd'hui on est sur un scénario qui
risque de faire partir les salariés de
cette activité du fret
et et je le dis parce que je pense que
c'est particulièrement effectivement
néfaste dans la situation qui est celle
de aujourd'hui de la SAS fret mais ça
s'ajoute finalement à une tendance qui
est beaucoup plus lourde c'est-à-dire
qu'on a un déficit d'attractivité
aujourd'hui des métiers du transport
notamment des métiers du transport
public et aussi du transport collectif
de voyageurs et que là s'agissant du
fret on est en train de de par cette
démarche proactive de la France qui ne
donne aucune assurance de décourager
finalement les salariés alors même qu'on
a ce déficit d'attractivité comment
voulez-vous en fait même s'il y a une
envie de train qu'on arrive à développer
en fait le frais de ferroviaire ou même
à le maintenir alors même que les
salariés seront des motivés des
mobilisés pour se faire
en prison par rapport à
j'ai le président par rapport à votre
question plusieurs éléments de réponse
déjà premier point à souligner
on l'avait dit d'ailleurs au ministre le
gouvernement veut pas s'engager à la
place des chargeurs généralement un
chargeur c'est industriel il fait ses
choix il fait des choix économiques il
fait des choix financiers et ce qu'on
sait par contre c'est que dès l'instant
où vous mettez en place ce genre de
scénario vous induisez un momentum où
les chargeurs se réinterrogent c'est à
dire qu'il peut y avoir des décisions
qui étaient peut-être dans les cartons
qui se précipitent des choses qui qui
avancent voilà et c'est l'occasion en
tout cas de dire potentiellement je
m'interrogeais parce qu'il est sur un
autre mode de transport voilà la
discontinuité elle peut être
accélératrice de décision ça c'est un
constat autre haute constat qu'on fait
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a on a un tout
petit peu on commence à avoir une
certaine vision sur un peu le comment
aujourd'hui c'est 23 flux ce serait
reporté on peut poser plusieurs constats
encore premier constat déjà c'est qu'il
y a certains chargeurs qui vont à closer
et qui vont qui vont activer la clause
de six mois pourquoi soit ils ont pas
pris leur décision ou soit aussi ce
qu'il faut aussi souligner c'est qu'ils
sont pas forcément mécontents du service
au contraire qui leur veut faire par
prête SNCF voilà on sait qu'aujourd'hui
et c'est quelque chose comme qui
constaté il y a un engagement
extrêmement fort des cheminots de
retraite SNCF en faveur du fractuaire il
y a une force des collectifs de travail
qui est comme un ennemiable et je pense
que je l'ai soigné tout à l'heure
pendant la crise sanitaire la SNCF d'une
manière assez large mais aussi que
c'était frette a fait la démonstration
qu'elle est une entreprise extrêmement
résiliante et qui paraissence avait une
valeur de service public qui était
intrinsèquement dans tous les cheminots
il y a ça aussi je pense que les
chargeurs constatent ce qu'on voit aussi
c'est que certains flux aujourd'hui ont
déjà ont déjà été transférés et on voit
là aussi des attitudes très différentes
des entreprises du secteur
certains entre guillemets seront
peut-être un petit peu précipités pour
aller reprendre les trafics et d'autres
sont beaucoup plus prudents voire même
très timoré pourquoi parce qu'ils savent
que ils se sont déjà un peu frottés ces
trafic les trafics du combiné c'est pas
les trafics les plus simples opérés
c'est les trains qui sont suivis c'est
les travaux il y a des exigences
extrêmement fortes des clients et
surtout Fred SNCF un atout si le
caractère mutualisé de ses activités qui
lui donnent des capacités en termes de
réactivité d'entreprise que certaines
entreprises concurrentes n'ont pas pour
jouer les pour gérer les aléas de
production vous comprenez qu'à travers
ma réponse on n'est pas là pour vous
dire telle ou tel chargeur d'ailleurs on
sait très bien que les décisions qui se
prennent qui sont même pas en France en
réalité ce qu'on rappelle que de
nombreux clients de fret aujourd'hui
c'est des multinationales ou des
entreprises dans les chaises sociaux
sont pas sont pas forcément en France
par contre ce qu'on veut aussi souligner
c'est qu'en ce moment on est dans un
moment qui est compliqué pour les
salariés de part ce choix aussi
potentiellement on a du mal à avoir à
avoir clair sur les choix des
industriels sur les choix des chargeurs
et en corollaire les risques
psychosociaux l'impact sur les salariés
et quand même exacerbé pourquoi parce
que c'est extrêmement compliqué
aujourd'hui de pouvoir prévoir une
gestion prévisionnelle de l'emploi
d'avoir un petit peu comment quel
dispositif effectivement de mobilité
notamment internes on pourrait mettre en
place quand vous avez pas la vision sur
les charges de travail que vous allez
avoir repéré à partir du 1er janvier
aujourd'hui on est dans ce moment-là et
ce moment-là il l'a il accentue le
caractère anxiogène de cette
discontinuité mais on vous développera
peut-être quand même voilà pour redire
un petit peu aussi comment ça s'est
passé à hauteur de salariés avec des
mois où on rappelle que tout ça ça n'a
été que finalement à l'état de rumeur
voilà donc les gens m'ont déjà comme
considérablement souffert avant
qu'effectivement le sujet arrive et on
voit qu'il y a eu une phase de
stupéfaction voilà une phase
d'étonnement qui aujourd'hui laisse la
place à une phase beaucoup plus de
colère voilà par rapport à une décision
ou au final je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure le constat qu'on commence en
tout cas que nous on porte et que je
pense qu'on commence à se rendre compte
c'est que tout ça à la fin ça va aboutir
à quoi c'est moins de train qui vont
coûter plus cher dans un moment où
public se fait rare enfin pour pour
finir je le disais tout à l'heure voilà
je pense que ce que on doit aussi
mesurer c'est le citer tout à l'heure
c'est l'effet de souffle sur le secteur
c'est à dire à moi on voit certaines
entreprises qui effectivement vous dire
clairement le VIH le bonheur des uns
enfin le meilleur des uns de faire le
bonheur des autres pour autant certaines
sont plus prudentes et se disent que
finalement ce qui se passe pour
l'opérateur historique il peut y avoir
un phénomène de désimbrication qui est
beaucoup plus important sur le secteur
et qu'au final on accélère une phase de
report modal qui finalement est
préjudiciable à l'intégralité du secteur
mais sans pour y revenir notamment quand
vous regardez un petit peu l'écosystème
aujourd'hui des entreprises ferroviaires
on voit que certaines ont trouvé
finalement un point d'équilibre sur des
marchés de niche par exemple sont sur
une taille organique qu'elles ont pas
forcément envie de voir se développer et
en gros il y a on va dire il y a une
concurrence qui est là mais qui se passe
dans un cadre
quand même pas forcément dans un cadre
de lutte au couteau et avec des gens qui
aussi voient combien ce qui se passe
pour Fred en disant finalement moi pour
y avoir aussi des impacts en tout cas
s'il y a un risque de report modal moi
j'en paierai aussi les conséquences
merci à vous avez c'est vous qui de loin
avait
dépassé le temps de parole des autres
organisations syndicales donc on s'en
souvient juste une remarque pour
Monsieur Mariani il est évident qu'une
remarque qu'on fait sur une notion de
discontinuité en droit au regard du
droit européen de la concurrence ne vaut
pas sur une notion de discontinuité en
droit quand on parle de droit du travail
français ou de code des transports
français c'est pas évidemment c'est pas
le même registre juridique et ça
beaucoup d'avocats peuvent l'expliquer
sans trop de sans trop de difficultés
et bon sud-ail pour la question globale
et ensuite on passera au rapporteur et
aux collègues parce que sinon il y aura
des frustrations
je sais pas combien j'ai de temps
puisque c'est enfin c'est pas militaire
en face donc compliqué de savoir alors
par rapport à la question
je vais me baser enfin je vais me baser
sur une étude du comité central
d'entreprise qui date de 2010 parce que
évidemment je me considère encore un
jeune cheminot même si ça fait longtemps
que je suis dans l'entreprise donc je
sais pas tout l'histoire mais je vous
invite à c'était prospective 2020 et
c'était une étude de comité central
d'entreprises en 2000 plutôt très
intéressantes et qui moi m'a permis
d'avoir une réflexion sur pourquoi on en
est arrivé là et ce que je peux vous
dire parce que j'ai bien senti on peut
mettre de côté l'ouverture à la
concurrence c'est la SNCF la Direction
SNCF donc vous avez eu tous les anciens
PDG devant vous n'a jamais pris en
considération les logiques et besoins
logistiques des clients ça veut dire
qu'il sait toujours contentée la
stratégie d'entreprise de vendre des
prestations de transport ferroviaire
souvent à prendre ou à laisser et je
l'ai dit dans mon intervention on
considère que en fait il doit y avoir
une vraie prise en charge d'un
développement enfin c'est pas que un
moyen de transport mais ça doit être
intégré dans la logistique et
actuellement on le voit je sais que
c'est d'une revendication qu'on porte
souvent ensemble bon bah on a des
centres des logistiques qui qui
fleurissent de plus en plus qui sont des
fois à côté d'une voie ferrée mais il y
a pas d'embranchement particulier qui
vont les desservir donc il y a jamais il
y a pas eu cette réflexion en gros un
petit peu intégré sur la Suisse enfin
vous avez pris l'exemple de la Suisse
l'absence de réglementation l'absence de
réglementation du trafic de transit
routier en France parce que en Suisse
c'est ce qui existe est une aberration
parce que le transit routier en France
sur des distances correspondant à ce qui
est considéré comme le créneau de
pertinence du rail entre 600 à 1000 km
représente environ une fois et demi le
trafic ferroviaire total mesuré en
milliard de de tonnes kilos en France
donc moi je voilà donc ensuite qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont fait mais je évidemment vous
le saviez mieux que moi c'est une
volonté politique et des contraintes un
peu plus un peu plus fortes je rappelle
juste vous le savez sûrement aussi le 6
juin 2023 si je me trompe pas les
Suisses ont René
CFF Cargo puisqu'on a l'entreprise
privée la société privée suisse combi
qui a jeté l'éponge donc on voit bien
que que là il y a pas de fin quand
quand il y a un sujet de renationaliser
ou de remettre des fonds publics il y a
pas il y a pas de souci et sur la
concurrence moi je me permets aussi de
rappeler enfin n'oublions pas que toutes
les nouvelles sociétés qui ont pris un
peu on va dire qu'on prie c'est trafic
ce sont des sociétés des filiales qui
derrière avaient des grands groupes
financiers ou alors des entreprises
historiques la Dodge Bank quand à France
on n'oublions enfin n'oublions pas ça
dans notre réflexion quand même ça veut
dire que derrière c'était voilà des
grands groupes financiers donc après
c'est pas ma zone au McDonald's c'est
pas réseau McDonald's c'est des
entreprises historiques ou avant on
parlait de coopération un peu entre
opérateurs historiques dans le
ferroviaire avec une volonté de
développer le ferroviaire et pas j'étais
aussi administrateur au conseil
d'administration on nous parlait de
guerre économiques il fallait jouer ce
qu'on appelle nous le cheminopoly et
après je comme on n'a pas trop le temps
de toute façon on a on a des mesures
enfin on l'avait on l'avait fait dans le
cadre de la Stratégie nationale à
l'époque par le ministre monsieur
Jebbari on avait fait des propositions S
mais des propositions concrètes avec
évidemment une vraie volonté politique
de bouleverser de bouleverser la
politique des transports dans ce pays
moi sur les deux premiers points de ce
que vous avez répondu je suis d'accord
avec vous
monsieur rapporteur vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président rebonjour à
vous à vous tous
plusieurs plusieurs questionnements
tout d'abord je m'adresse aux
représentant de la CFDT je souhaiterais
que la suite de cette audience vous
puissiez nous communiquer par écrit
un élément de l'élément d'information
que vous nous avez communiqué tout à
l'heure c'est à dire les conditions et
les propos dans lesquels ont été conclus
ont été tenus en 2019 dites-vous
portant assurance
sur
à la fois la viabilité et la pérennité
de l'entreprise ainsi créée et aussi et
où
l'euro compatibilité de la solution qui
vous avait été présentée c'est un
élément
important dans
selon moi tout du moins dans la
progression du travail d'enquête de la
de la commission
j'en profite pour élargir mon propos
peut-être toujours vous-même Messier
CFDT pour vous demander si et bien sûr
cela s'adresse à tout un chacun si vous
avez été depuis lors puisque la date de
2019 semble être un élément important
pour cranter les échanges y compris les
échanges en direction et les
organisations syndicales pour savoir si
vous avez été associé à un
quelconquement et sous une quelconque
forme par
l'émergence à un moment donné à un
moment x d'une solution de discontinuité
et ce avant évidemment le mois de
janvier dernier deuxième question
troisième question le ministre lors de
son audience indiquée qui s'était forcé
de
garantir trois lignes rouges majeures
dans ce plan de discontinuité
l'aspect social et vous nous dites vous
nous dites
que les continents les conditions de la
continuité du cadre social n'est pas
garantie pourriez-vous préciser alors
que l'un de ces arguments porte sur
effectivement les garanties sociales
pourriez-vous nous préciser votre point
de vue sur ce point dans le cadre donc
de la prochaine entité deuxième élément
c'est la viabilité de la nouvelle entité
nous avons interrogé simplement de
dirigeants qui
à ma question sur un minima une étude
d'impact nous ont dit qu'effectivement
cela avait eu lieu est-ce que vous avez
est-ce que vous avez eu connaissance
d'une étude d'impact portant et
garantissant la viabilité de la future
entité et quand
c'est Sud qui indiquaient que cette
viabilité n'était pas garantie
pourriez-vous donc
messieurs de dessus de développer votre
argumentaire en la matière et notamment
par rapport et bien on segment du
transport mutualisé qui est prévu pour
cette entité troisième élément et c'est
un
c'est une information importante puisque
il y a moins d'une semaine un troisième
garantie qui était la garantie d'ordre
environnemental
sans pouvoir s'engager sur cette
question
monsieur le ministre indiqué que c'était
une ligne rouge et que y compris ça
prendrait le temps que ça prendrait avec
six mois un an pour pour aboutir au
transfert de flux mais vous nous dites
que d'ores et déjà deux flux
retourné sur la route est-ce que vous
pouvez nous confirmer cette information
et la consolidée enfin peut-être
maîtresse
de la CGT le ministre le ministre parle
désormais d'un fait acquis que ce plan
de discontinuité est-ce que
vous disposez de propositions
alternatives à court terme car nous
sommes dans l'urgence qui pourrait être
offert l'objet
d'une voix politique
de la France à nouveau réouverte auprès
de la Commission européenne et enfin une
dernière une dernière question peut-être
à vous toutes et j'ai pas dit non
madame à vous tous c'est de dire voilà
vous n'êtes pas sans avoir
vous n'êtes pas sans avoir des échanges
inter syndicaux à l'échelle européenne
et notamment avec vos collègues
également avez-vous
des réactions des appréciations
sur la manière dont notamment les
syndicats allemands perçoivent
appréhendent tout à la fois la procédure
ouverte contre
la filière et à la demande et la posture
que le gouvernement allemand adopte dans
l'État vis-à-vis de l'ouverture de
l'enquête de la Commission européenne
merci
voilà je vais toujours tout de suite
répondre à la première oui nous avons
des échanges avec nos camarades
allemands mais plus généralement avec
tous les tous les syndicats qui sont
membres de TF les syndicats allemands
nous répondent un peu gênés qu'il ne
n'engageront pas spécialement
d'autres choses que des déclarations
parce que leur gouvernement se défendra
mieux que le nôtre
voilà donc
il souhaite pas spécialement est
embourbé dans les dans les positions
dans les positionnements français alors
que effectivement en général l'Allemagne
c'est bien défendre ses intérêts
bon voilà
ce ne sont évidemment que les
appréciations enfin ça ça donne un peu
l'état d'esprit quelques éléments sur
la situation de de cette discontinuité
oui nous avons été alertés comme je
disais par les militants sur la
discontinuité mais à aucun moment nous
n'avons été associés
par le par le gouvernement a
[Musique]
aux décisions qui étaient déjà prises en
fait puisque nous avons rencontré j'ai
moi-même rencontré le directeur de
cabinet d'Elisabeth borne suite à une
intervention de Sophie Binet secrétaire
général de la CGT auprès d'Elizabeth
borne le sujet était déjà clos c'était
au mois d'août si je ne me trompe pas et
on nous a plutôt défendu la position
déjà établie que véritablement présenté
les différentes options les différentes
options nous les avons eu par radio
ballast comme le disent certains
collègues avec les trois options
possibles de la
de la de la procédure la liquidation
l'abandon l'abandon de procédure et la
discontinuité le fait que cette
discontinuité devait
considérer entre 20 et 50% des marchés
et un changement de nature de
l'entreprise etc etc tout ça nous
l'avons appris par nos
ressources militantes voilà nous n'avons
été à associés à rien de ça et c'est ce
qui nous étonne énormément c'est que
nous aurions aimé débattre des critiques
que nous avons pourquoi est-ce que le
l'intégralité du plan
du plan de réorganisation du fret sur
les 15 dernières années n'a pas été
défendu par le gouvernement d'ailleurs
nous avons eu des échanges avec la
commissaire européen je ne me rappelle
plus son nom parce que s'il est
compliqué
voilà qui
nous faisait part de deux choses
premièrement son étonnement sur la
précipitation du gouvernement français
alors c'est ce qu'elle nous a dit à nous
on a le temps on va examiner les choses
on a 18 mois et voir plus si nécessaire
et puis dans un deuxième temps sont son
étonnement sur nos argumentation donc
nous on aurait aimé vraiment pouvoir
débattre avec la SNCF et la direction de
l'entreprise et le et le gouvernement
est-il possible par exemple de tracer
les flux financiers de fret sur les 15
dernières années pas simplement ces
déficits ces résultats enfin c'est oui
c'est c'est résultats nettes directs
mais aussi ce qu'il a généré comme
produit de cession et tout ce que nous
avons pu soulever et également la
commissaire européen nous disait que si
le gouvernement français avait fait à
chaque étape à chaque nouveau plan une
note
d'informations sur le fait que c'était
la continuité du premier il était pas
impossible alors elle sait pas
engagé mais il était pas impossible que
ça ça ait pu être intégré comme
respectant les règles de de l'Union
européenne sur les restructurations des
secteurs publics donc bon voilà on est
très très interrogatif difficile
effectivement de peser sur la situation
puisque les courriers de désengagement
de l'entreprise sont partis donc les
contrats ont été dénoncés alors il est
toujours possible de revenir en arrière
mais
voilà ça suppose quelques actions aussi
et nous avons immédiatement quand nous
avons su que les courriers étaient en
phase de préparation nous avons
immédiatement interpellé gouvernement
pour qu'il fasse cesser ça au moins le
temps qu'on s'assure que véritablement
les trafics puissent être repris et
notamment le l'emblématique Perpignan
Rungis mais bon nous constatons que nos
alertes n'ont pas été écoutés que
maintenant la proposition qui est faite
c'est finalement que Fred SNCF pourrait
continuer à sous-traiter pour
pour on ne sait pas trop qui en
définitive donc on se demande si on va
pas monter notre propre entreprise
ferroviaire pour l'armée on est dans des
situations quand même qui nous sommes
extrêmement caricatural extrêmement
caricatural et si je peux me permettre
sur le Perpignan Rungis la proposition
qui est faite dans la nouvelle amie
nouvel appel à manifestation d'intérêt
c'est 12 millions de surventions par an
nous on avait en 2020 il va évoluer le
fait qu'il fallait 1000 équivaliers en
Perpignan Rungis pour atteindre 25% de
par modèle il faudrait 12 milliards de
financement public
et ensuite on vient nous faire la leçon
à nous sur le fait que nos solutions
sont coûteuses nos solutions de l'argent
public et rare etc là on a vraiment
l'impression que il faut tout faire pour
sauver le plan
la réforme de 2018 en tout cas quoi
qu'il en coûte quoi voilà sur un petit
point également sur la situation
ferroviaire en général parce que je
voudrais pas qu'il soit considéré aussi
par la commission que seuls frais et
SNCF est en difficulté
l'accompagner ECR qui est filiale de la
Lunch ban et qui est le principal
concurrent fêté SNCF en France n'a
pratiquement pas eu et je crois qu'il
n'a même pas eu du tout un seul exercice
excédentaire depuis sa création il y a
eu une recapité de réalisation il y a
quelques années de 150 millions d'euros
les derniers exercices c'est moins 15
millions en 2018 - 3 millions 2019 - 15
millions 2020 - 1,8 millions en 2021
pour un chiffre d'affaires de 150
millions donc on est à 10 % de perte la
plupart des années voilà la situation du
fret elle n'est absolument pas réglée
par par
le système les le plan de relance qui a
été vanté par Elisabeth borne tout à
l'heure
la stratégie je sais plus comment
alterne la stratégie nationale fret
il a permis de faire surnager les
principales entreprises parce qu'en
vérité au moment où il a été mis en
place s'il n'était pas mis en place non
seulement Fred se retrouver en
difficulté mais toutes les entreprises
concurrentes étaient en voie de
très grande précarité à l'exception des
marchés de niche comme le disait je ne
sais plus quel de mes camarades les
marchés de Nice qui correspondent à
fournir du fret aux travaux mais la
plupart du temps aux travaux de la SNCF
donc c'est compagnies qui font les
travaux effectivement celle-là sont
rentables on pourrait s'interroger
d'ailleurs sur les conditions
d'attribution de marché dans le domaine
voilà quelques éléments supplémentaires
sur sur
le ce que disent aujourd'hui
plus généralement puis après peut-être
un mot sur les propositions les
chargeurs de leurs difficultés les
chargeurs sont globalement satisfaits de
la SNCF deux problématiques
les trains qui ne sont pas assurés aux
horaires prévus
donc les sillons horaires qui ne sont
pas respectés et le par exemple le
Groupement National du transport combiné
estime ce nombre de sillon non respectés
à 30%. 30% liés exclusivement à la
logique des travaux de nuit
il a été prévu 70 millions de budget
pour améliorer cette situation bon sur
un budget de réseau de 4 milliards je
pense qu'on va pas améliorer grand chose
et surtout fondamentalement on voit que
la production de l'Infra rentre en
confrontation avec la production des
exploitants et et la confrontation des
intérêts c'est quelque chose que nous
avons beaucoup dénoncé et sur lequel
plus on avance plus les intérêts sont
divergents et le deuxième sujet c'est le
coût de l'énergie et je me dois quand
même d'y faire référence en 2021 on
avait 56 millions alors 56 euros du
mégawattheure on est à 475 et donc la
demande des chargeurs c'est de
réguler le marché ce qui est cocasse
et de limiter le prix à 180 euros du
mégawatt donc la régulation finalement
c'est une chose positive
si vous me permettez juste je précise en
tant que président de cette commission
d'enquête que sur les échanges que vous
évoquiez d'une part avec les contacts du
cabinet de la Première ministre vous
disiez en doute je pense c'était en août
2023 puisque vous citiez le nom de la
secrétaire général de la CGT qui n'était
pas en 2022 donc c'est en août 2023
plusieurs semaines après l'annonce de la
solution de discontinuité le 23 mai pour
lesquelles se faire un appareil il y a
eu il y avait eu un échange avec les
organisations syndicales un tout petit
peu avant ça doit être vers le 14 mai
mais on en reparlera donc sur ces ce
contact évidemment on sera demandeur de
l'établir et même chose sur les contacts
avec
la commissaire européenne c'est une
demande qu'on adresse à tous ceux qui
mentionnent des contacts avec des traces
écrites et notamment de ce que vous
évoquez sur le défaut d'information à la
suite des différents plans parce que ça
voudrait dire que si il y a eu
une remontée d'information sur la
stratégie du fret par différents
gouvernements et d'ailleurs de
différentes tendances politiques qui a
été insuffisantes et qui aurait pu
peut-être nuancer le regard qui a été
porté sur l'activité de ferroviaire donc
là on sera en demande de d'éléments
écrits sur ce que vous attribuez à la
commissaire européenne mais évidemment
c'est intéressant cette commission
monsieur Gomet vouliez
compléter oui juste compléter très
rapidement sur les questions qui sont
posées bien évidemment sur les échanges
avec les autres syndicats européens
peut-être informer aussi la commission
d'enquête que il y a une procédure qui
est ouverte depuis 2015 en Roumanie et
que depuis 2015 la Roumanie et la
Commission européenne discute
négocie mais en tout cas l'opérateur
historique roumain existe toujours il
n'y a pas donc de procédure de
discontinuité économique de cette
structure c'est peut-être aussi une
volonté de discuter de façon longue et
appropriée dans un pays qui est certes
moins de poids économiques que la France
et qui a donc moins de diplomaties de
poids dans la Commission européenne en
tout cas eux ils y arrivent sur
l'association est-ce qu'on parle d'une
pour la cas de la Roumanie qu'on a qu'on
n'avait pas évoqué jusqu'à présent
est-ce qu'on parle d'une enquête
approfondie ou d'une procédure ouverte
par des plaintes par d'autres
entreprises comme c'était le cas pour la
France depuis 2016
c'est une procédure européenne également
dans le cadre d'aide illicite au secteur
ferroviaire à l'opérateur historique
roumain sur
l'association à l'émergeant d'une
solution de discontinuité ou de
discussion qui aurait pu avoir avec
l'entreprise
j'ai été secrétaire du comité de groupe
SNCF de la période 2018 à 2022 et donc
juste après post-réfond ferroviaire et
donc nous avons eu énormément de
discussions sur la mise en place de
cette réforme ferroviaire et
spécifiquement sur la création de la SAS
Fred qui est intervenu au 1er janvier
2020 les discussions qui ne sont pour la
pour beaucoup
informel non écrite mais en tout cas qui
revêtent quand même un caractère que je
pense la Commission doit être mise au
courant
des dès la promulgation en fait
finalement de la réforme le 27 juin 2018
les dirigeants de l'entreprise nous
disent bon il y a un risque très fort
sur la SAS fraté SNCF c'est le point
faible c'est le point faible de cette
réforme du ferroviaire et notamment que
va dire la Commission européenne alors
pour reprendre les propos pas
inextensaux mais à l'époque de certains
dirigeants nous disent bon si jamais les
pets Damoclès s'abat sur nous bon on
liquidera la société nouvellement créée
de toute façon les en plus c'est été
créé sous la forme simplifiée
on est quand même sur une entreprise
d'un milliard d'euros et de 5000
salariés
et ont créé une société anonyme
simplifiée une SAS c'est quand même dans
le paysage un peu particulier maintenant
c'était pas interdit bien entendu c'est
une forme juridique qui existe et que
d'autres entreprises peuvent utiliser
mais en tout cas elle n'est pas dotée
d'un conseil d'administration la SS
c'est pas le Téné conseil
d'administration il y a très peu de
discussions enfin voilà c'est c'est très
simple en fait de la de l'amph plus de
la liquider ou de la supprimer donc nous
on peut s'interroger on s'interroger
déjà à l'époque d'ailleurs on peut vous
fournir nos écrits si vous voulez de la
période 2018 même jusqu'à très récemment
sur en fait le la mise en place de la
SAS Fret SNCF et des conséquences qu'il
pourrait y avoir en fait sur cette
société et déjà à l'époque on disait
qu'elle était un peu mort nez cette
société puisqu'il y avait tellement de
risques qui posaient sur elle que voilà
il y avait quand même des gros soucis de
viabilité de cette structure bon
manifestement on arrive finalement à une
procédure de discontinuité qui pour nous
finalement est une procédure du
liquidation voilà on l'appelle comment
on souhaite mais c'est une liquide à
Sion de la société
peut-être aussi également
vous dire quelques mots sur la
construction aussi financière et
organisationnelle de la de la SNCF quand
le 1er janvier 2020 la SAS fret nez
finalement cette société elle existe
déjà voilà puisque la SNCF est une
intégrale utilise l'intégration fiscale
et la fête SNCF SAS est créée au 1er
janvier 2017
et seulement activé au 1er janvier 2020
la réforme du ferroviaire intervient le
juin 2018
vous voyez un an et demi avant on a créé
déjà la structure la société
avant la réforme du ferroviaire et on la
nourrit on le transfère de ses actifs
dans la nuit du 31 décembre 2019 au 1er
janvier 2020 tout ça pour vous dire que
il y a quand même des choses qui sont
connues ça a été maintenant reconnu par
les différents auditions sur le fait que
oui on savait qu'il y avait un risque et
puis qui avait des plainte depuis 2016
c'est pas quelque chose qui a été vécu
comme un choc dans l'entreprise ou dans
le gouvernement même si ça a été dit
comme ça au départ puisque ces choses là
étaient largement
établie et connu pour conclure
vous demandez également que via le
comité d'établissement de fret SNCF et
comme la procédure européenne le permet
nous avons demandé la lettre associée au
débat et être entendu par cette par
cette commission
d'obser par la commission par Bruxelles
puisque nous avons fait un donc un
déclaratif mandataire un avocat nous
avons rempli tous les documents
nécessaires parce que nous considérons
nous sommes partis intéressés dans ce
dossier comme la loi européenne le oit à
ce jour les réponses de la Commission
européenne
n'ont pas eu lieu dans les premiers
échanges qu'on peut avoir de façon orale
voilà comme en fait il y a la procédure
qui est mise en place et que le deal est
en train d'être passé entre le
gouvernement et
et la Commission européenne et a pas
besoin d'entendre les parties les
parties intéressées ou d'autres parties
prenantes quoi
et donc ça aussi ça mériterait d'être
exploré puisque
on nous représentons 5000 salariés
et nous pouvons même pas être entendus
par la commission européenne alors que
la loi européenne le permet
et vous dire également qu'il y a eu un
droit d'alerte économique comme la loi
française cette fois-ci le prévoit voilà
sur les conséquences en fait économiques
que celui-ci prend un temps relativement
long et que l'entreprise et le
gouvernement ne souhaitent pas attendre
les conclusions de la commission
d'enquête qui aura lieu certainement fin
d'année mais également du droit d'alerte
économique déposé en CSE avant de
réaliser la discontinuité c'est à dire
que peut-être qu'on va arriver à un
moment où on aura des conclusions qui
nous montrerons que c'est pas la bonne
solution de faire la discontinuité mais
que le gouvernement aura demandé avec la
SNCF de la faire et qu'on pourra plus
revenir en arrière et ça c'est un peu
buette puisqu'on a le temps vous voyez
d'autres pays européens comme
l'Allemagne l'Allemagne la procédure a
commencé il y a deux ans et comme le
rembranle la stipulée les contacts que
nous avons avec les amants c'est dire oh
là là mais nous on négocie vous
inquiétez pas nous on va s'en sortir
c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait qu'on se
précipite pas donc on se demande mais ça
c'est juste une réflexion personnelle et
syndicale on peut pas les payer on se
demande si finalement c'est une aubaine
cette procédure de la Commission
européenne parce qu'il était temps en
fait finalement d'en finir avec un
opérateur public et puis de passer à
autre chose et de changer quatre
sociales et puis vraiment parce que
voilà
il y avait encore oui mais je pense que
enfin je dis juste que d'ici une
demi-heure on va tous se séparer donc il
faut aussi que les collègues puissent
poser des questions mais
et je remarque Sud est d'une ça se sont
assez peu exprimées jusqu'à présent un
peu moins longtemps que les autres en
tout cas il y a pas de souci donc si
vous souhaitez pour les prendre la
parole c'est bien volonté que je voulais
dire merci monsieur le Président donc
écoutez on va répondre aux quatre
questions qui ont été posées donc
assez rapidement a-t-on été associés à
une solution de discontinuité non tout
comme tout comme vous en fait on a pris
le 18 janvier que fraté SNCF était
allé être une enquête de la Commission
européenne elle est avait été ouverte
pour des aides illégales donc suite à ça
nous avons été reçus par le ministre et
la direction de l'entreprise de fret
SNCF et du groupe pour pour nous
expliquer un petit peu ce que ce que
l'État voulait faire sur sur le dossier
donc nous au moment là il y avait il y
avait plusieurs choses dans les dans les
tiroirs donc la première chose c'était
on laisse aller l'enquête au bout au
bout de son instruction et suite à ça on
est blanchi on doit rien à personne tout
va bien deuxième solution c'était on est
reconnu coupable au bout de des 18 mois
ou 24 mois d'enquête et on doit
rembourser les 5 milliards troisième
solution c'était la fameuse
discontinuité donc la fameuse
discontinuité on l'a pris le 23 mai par
le gouvernement monsieur Clément Boone
qui a décidé d'appliquer cette
discontinuité donc avant nous n'avions
absolument aucun échange sur cette
discontinuité
posé la question sur le cadre social
garantie ou non garantie à cette
heure-ci le cadre social est non garanti
la seule chose qu'on sait c'est que le
cadre social va être discuté pour les
deux nouvelles entités et le cadre
social ne va pas être le même que nous
avons actuellement la sastreet c'est un
cadre social qui sera clairement au
rabais et si on accepte pas de discuter
du cadre social de toute façon ça sera
les menaces d'application de l'accord de
branche sur sur le cadre social
la viabilité de la nouvelle entité donc
la viabilité de la nouvelle entité
clairement avec l'enquête que nous avons
actuellement sur de la Commission
européenne les chargeurs sont en train
de perdre de confiance complètement au
frais SNCF donc c'est mathématique si
les clients sent bon ou alors des
entreprises ferroviaires privées ou à la
route
il y a plus de clients il y a plus
d'argent l'entreprise ferme voilà ça
c'est mathématique avons voulu eu
connaissance d'une étude d'impact
environnemental non on a eu aucune
connaissance d'un impact environnemental
ce qu'on peut vous dire actuellement
c'est qu'à cette heure-ci il y a déjà
une entité officielle qui s'est
positionnée pour reprendre les flux sur
ses propres moyens humains et sur ses
propres moyens matériels donc à cette
heure-ci tout le monde sait sur le
marché du ferroviaire qu'on est en flux
tendu sur le matériel sur les
conducteurs qui sont une denré très rare
il y en a pas personne n'en a donc ça
veut dire que si une entreprise
ferroviaire privée se positionne avec
ses propres moyens sur des flux
rentables et plus que rentable ça veut
dire que forcément ils pourront pas
faire le marché les marchés qu'ils ont
actuellement donc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire une chose ça veut dire au
niveau environnemental ça veut dire du
report modal inversé ça repart à la
route ça c'est pareil c'est mathématique
réaction des homologues allemands bon
bah comme les collègues de la CGT on vit
à ETF on a des échanges avec avec les
homologues allemands les homologues
allemands n'ont pas forcément quelque
chose à dire ni à faire puisque pour
l'instant
officiellement le gouvernement fait
statu quo et n'a pris aucune décision
donc s'ils veulent aller jusque jusque
la fin jusqu'à la fin de l'enquête de la
Commission européenne donc c'est que ils
sont sûrs de deux donc bon on verra qui
qui du gouvernement allemand ou qui du
gouvernement français
a raison voilà j'en ai terminé merci
pour pour compléter très rapidement de
voix enfin dans l'une des questions
c'était les fameuses lignes rouges qui
ont été données enfin qui ont été
affichés nous on le réaffirme et ça a
été dit le report modal va être inversé
là on déstabilise un secteur il n'y a
pas que les organisations syndicales qui
le disent il y a Alexandre Gallo je sais
pas si vous l'avez vu vous allez bientôt
le voir le 25 mai dans l'article vie du
rail transport qui dit les menaces qui
pèsent sur Fred SNCF ne sont pas une
bonne nouvelle ni pour le marché ni pour
les chargeurs ni pour l'environnement et
je donnerai juste un exemple très
concret parce que la SNCF a quand on dit
à une capacité de mutualisation ou
fédératrice ça veut dire qu'on a des
cheminots et des cheminotes qui sont à
la fois pour le train dédié ou enfin et
où les trafic gestion capacitaires et
concrètement il y a une organisation qui
est en place je vous donnerai l'exemple
des eaux déviants qui datent il y a un
peu longtemps où il y avait une
organisation du travail à un gros voilà
Danone un gros client et une
organisation que la SNCF avec deux
machines qui allait bien l'entreprise
qui allait bien au chargeur et la SNCF a
voulu réorganiser et en fait il y a la
perdue le marché parce qu'on a
déstabilisé le marché on a
déstabilisageurs donc c'est ce qui est
en train de se passer et si ce qui nous
permet d'afficher dans cette commission
d'enquête avec en ayant posément au
début que oui le report moderne inversé
malgré tout ce qu'on dit va arriver
parce que on a déstabilisé un secteur
aujourd'hui avec des habitudes
d'organisation vous le comprenez tout et
tous qu'évidemment quand on va livrer un
train dans une usine bon bah
l'entreprise elle a mis des salariés en
face qui sont là le jour la nuit ou
d'une manière pour réceptionner la
marchandise donc vraiment il y a ce cas
là et il complétera Guillaume
concrètement sur quel marché
depuis l'annonce de discontinuité toute
façon dans la liste des 23 flux c'est
très factuel il y a déjà deux flux qui
ne circulent plus donc le Bettembourg
Barcelone de L'Oréal ne circule plus et
le
Valenton 7 n'a jamais été lancé donc ces
deux flux qui n'ont jamais été lancés
donc soit les marchandises transitent
dans des camions soit on ne sait pas où
elles sont passées mais en tout cas
c'est du repas modal sur la viabilité de
la nouvelle entité
pour nous ça repose sur une série de
conditions qui ne sont pas du tout
garanties il faut soutenir le frais de
ferroviaire par des aides suffisamment
suffisantes et durable c'est pas du tout
garanti actuellement il faut pouvoir
compter sur un rythme de croissance et
on le voit les marchandises lors des 20
dernières années sur le rail c'est pas
ce qui a été le plus croissant
il faut savoir aussi compter sur une
poursuite inaccélération de la
productivité alors ça après tous les
plans sociaux que les cheminots ont subi
je pense que c'est un petit peu
difficile à entendre il faut aussi un
soutien fort de l'actionnaire
l'actionnaire actuellement de la SNCF
c'est l'état et ça non plus c'est pas
garanti puisqu'on veut même ouvrir le
capital de la nouvelle entreprise
donc ça c'est les points sur lesquels on
voulait revenir sur sur les lignes
rouges et la ligne rouge du cadre social
ça nous a déjà été annoncé par la DRH de
l'entreprise elle ne veut pas transposer
les accords actuels dans la nouvelle
société donc c'est pas pour faire du
plus pour les employés
pour répondre aux questions du
rapporteur d'abord pour vous dire qu'on
pourra vous le mettre par écrit a été
créé à l'époque en 2019 un groupe de
travail des administrateurs à
l'initiative du territoire du groupe
public ferroviaire c'est réunion n'ont
pas donné lieu à des comptes rendus mais
j'ai sous les yeux les notes qui avaient
été prises par les administrateurs donc
je faisais partie et qui disait que le
dispositif avec le l'unité d'affaires
fret avec un compte de dette séparés
mais situé dans la sa holding avec été
présenté à l'époque à la Commission
européenne alors les trois possibilités
rappelées par Monsieur le doc notamment
avait été explicité sur ce que pouvait
faire la commission mais ce qui avait
été dit à l'époque c'est que ce
dispositif a été présenté à la
Commission européenne et n'a pas suscité
d'observation
par ailleurs l'État pourra s'opposer aux
décisions de la commission et tout ça a
été évidemment corroboré par une
position de l'État puisqu'on avait des
rencontres à l'époque avec le ministre
des Transports qui était Jean-Baptiste
Djebari qui nous avait dit évidemment le
scénario le discontinuité n'était pas
son scénario préféré et que l'État se
positionnerait contre une décision de la
commission qui viendrait remettre en
cause cette position actuellement
exprimée de neutralité en tout cas qui
nous était relatés comme tel voilà et
exactement les signaux qui avaient été
envoyés et effectivement on n'a pas eu
ensuite de situation intermédiaire ou un
scénario de discontinuité aurait été
préparé avec nous c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné on est arrivé avec
finalement ça sera la discontinuité donc
voilà en résumé et voyez que enfin de ce
que disent nos collègues pour répondre à
votre deuxième question que le il y a
enfin moi j'aimerais vous croire et on
aimerait tous vous croire Monsieur le
Président sur le fait que il y a une
assurance sur le fait que
l'application du discontinuité sur le
plan du droit européen ne fera pas
obstacle le disposition de la loi
nouveau pacte ferroviaire qui fait
référence aux activités exercées au 31
décembre 2019 par le groupe public
ferroviaire mais c'est ambiguïté elle
existe tenter si bien que vous voyez
bien les scénarios de continuité du cas
de social qui sont présentées
aujourd'hui à l'intérieur du groupe
notamment par la SAS fret et donc la
continuité du cas social en tout cas
c'est pas ce qui est ce qui est projeté
aux salariés à l'heure actuelle en tout
cas par le par les représentants de la
société fret
pour préciser il s'agissait pas de
croire ou ne pas me croire c'était
simplement une remarque qui consistait à
dire que deux droites différents
n'en portaient pas des conséquences
identiques c'est simplement ça mais ça
c'est une règle de droit classique moi
je n'ai pas pris d'engagement je suis
pas en situation de prendre des
engagements sur quoi que ce soit sur le
sac à dos social de salariés de prêter
SNCF ça se saurait alors on va prendre
les questions à la suite des différents
collègues de façon à ce que vous
puissiez répondre ensemble et que
personne n'est de frustration donc on a
des questions de Madame tienia de Madame
la rapporteur spécial à Rigi et de
monsieur porte madame la vice-présidente
une seule président monsieur bonjour moi
je vais vous poser trois questions la
première c'est pas de quel moyen
estimez-vous judiciaire de soutenir
l'objectif du doublement de la part
model du fret à horizon 2030 je sais que
c'est un sujet important dans la
planification écologique et plus
précisément dans cette perspective
qui propose vous pour que le coût du
fret routier s'équilibre avec le coût
des frites ferroviaire c'est aussi un
grand sujet et dans quelle mesure la
prise en compte des enjeux
environnementaux structures
vos stratégies en matière de frais de
ferroviaire puisque je sais que les
syndicats travaillent aussi sur ces
sujets et pour finir j'aimerais relayer
l'inquiétude des entreprises qui sont
amenées à faire transporter leurs
produits via le fret il y a bien sûr
deux aspects quand il s'agit de
matériaux non périssables il y a pas de
sujet S mais quand il s'agit de denrées
alimentaires il y a beaucoup plus de
frein aujourd'hui donc qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez dire pour essayer de les
rassurer parce que comme vous le savez
pour que les frais puissent se
développer on a besoin du concours de
chacun je vous remercie
merci la vice-présidente madame la
rapporteur spéciale
merci monsieur le Président messieurs
donc puisque Ilan est ainsi merci pour
l'ensemble de vos
contributions extrêmement documentées et
surtout que je trouve qui témoigne de
votre attachement à votre métier et à la
grande famille du fret Jean-Pierre
pernandou que nous avons auditionné hier
ou avant-hier témoigner également de
cette attachement à cette grande maison
du fret et c'est important parce que
aujourd'hui dans le cadre des mobilités
on le sait le fret quelqu'un d'entre
vous l'avez dit plusieurs c'est beaucoup
moins de gaz à effet de serre c'est
beaucoup moins de carbone de carbone de
pensée et c'est un coût de qui au niveau
de la société
économise effectivement nous permet
d'aller vers la neutralité carbone
contrairement au tout poids lourd et
donc justement à ce propos j'entendu
également les sentiments de défiance par
rapport aux engagement passé qui avait
été qui sont qui ont été exprimés
l'évocation d'un paradoxe qui
aujourd'hui fait que en supprimant cette
entité frette et ne la garantissant pas
pour l'avenir et bien on pourrait
remettre du camion sur la route
également le découragement des
personnels et la perte potentielle de
compétences et puis également je tiens à
le souligner un historique extrêmement
intéressante qui a été fait par Monsieur
je vois pas très bien gommer sur je le
découvre que la SAS prête avait été créé
en 1er janvier 2017 pacte ferroviaire
puis SAS activé en 2020 et donc du coup
j'en arrive à ma question sur d'abord
l'assurance témoignée sur le scénario de
discontinuité qui serait garantit
juridiquement rien n'est moins sûr et en
tout cas de cause avez-vous une réponse
de la Commission européenne je pense que
non mais j'aimerais vous l'entendre dire
sur le fait que ça garantit complètement
cette discontinuité et complètement
garantie juridiquement c'est pas une
question de droit facile et du coup je
la repose très clairement ensuite
vous chacun son saisira s'il le souhaite
puisque je m'adresse à vous tous vous
est-il venu à l'esprit que le
durcissement de la Commission européenne
soit directement liée à la volonté du
gouvernement de se débarrasser du
sparadrap de la dette fret et de ce que
la solution apportée aujourd'hui comme
un moindre mal par rapport au
langagement du procédure puisse avoir
été vous avez dit les négocier au niveau
national puisque faut citer l'exemple
par exemple de la Roumanie ou les
négociations et les discussions se
tiennent depuis bien longtemps et donc
pourquoi alors que depuis 2006 25 ans de
patience de la Communauté européenne
tout d'un coup en 2022 cette Commission
européenne qui était qui connaissait le
dossier depuis si longtemps ou rédurci
sa position et pourquoi finalement cette
solution qui nous est apportée ne serait
pour sauver le fret ne serait en réalité
que la réponse du gouvernement une
volonté précédemment exprimée mais qui
n'avait pas pu se déployer
monsieur le député de Seine-Saint-Denis
chers collègues merci monsieur le
Président moi j'ai plusieurs d'abord je
vous remercie pour pour les
présentations et pour les éléments que
vous avez amenés dans le dans le débat
qui sont utiles
j'ai deux questions pour les
représentants de la CGT
il a été évoqué tout à l'heure que
c'était la continuité quelque part des
plantes qui avaient été menées à Fred
SNCF et que
vous avez dit c'est une opération de
privatisation est-ce que vous pouvez
préciser ces propos là et d'ailleurs je
j'ai pas eu la réponse tout à l'heure
quand j'ai posé la question à Elisabeth
band sur pourquoi on sépare là
maintenant dans la future entité
Jean-Pierre farando quand je l'ai
interrogé à 17 une punition c'est pas
véritablement une réponse qui me
convient donc j'aimerais savoir si vous
vous avez une idée pourquoi on sait pas
aujourd'hui là maintenant et deuxième
question pour vous vous avez parlé vous
avez évoqué les sillons plusieurs
intervenants ont évoqué la question de
la non régénération du réseau donc des
travaux de nuit donc l'impossibilité de
faire circuler des trains de fret la
nuit en raison des travaux or il me
semble de mémoire que avant on savait
faire passer des trains avait en faisant
des travaux et j'ai posé la question sur
l'impact de la sous-traitance dans les
travaux et des conséquences que ça avait
sur la circulation des trains ce matin
monsieur rapport que vous connaissez a
dit c'est stabilisé c'est-à-dire qu'il
n'y a pas de recours massif à la
sous-traitance par rapport à 10 ans ça
n'a pas beaucoup évolué c'est stabilisé
j'aimerais avoir votre votre point de
vue là dessus aujourd'hui à quel niveau
on est de sous-traitance sur les travaux
est-ce que c'est un impact véritable sur
la circulation des trains la nuit
notamment au regard de la formation au
risque ferroviaire des gens qui sont pas
des cheminots et donc avec une fermeture
de voie et j'ai deux questions pour SUD
Rail et je n'arrête là-dessus vous avez
parlé du syndrome France Télécom
quand on a posé la question à
Jean-Pierre farando sur quid de l'avenir
des salariés de fret SNCF il a semblé
dire que il y avait une certaine
facilité pour les conducteurs puisqu'il
serait transféré à TER pour une partie
parce que il y avait des besoins mais il
n'y a pas que les conducteurs qui sont
concernés par on peut appeler ça des
suppressions d'emploi en tout cas des
reclassements dans le groupe ferroviaire
donc aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui est mis
en place par l'entreprise sur ce par
rapport à ça et par rapport au sentiment
con les salariés et pour bien comprendre
ce que vous avez dit vous avez dit le
est déjà inversé vous avez cité deux
trafics qui sont à l'arrêt sur 23 est-ce
que c'est d'appréciation qu'on a sur
déjà deux trafics sur 23 est-ce que vous
pensez qu'elle va se généraliser sur les
autres trafic est-ce que vous avez de
réels inquiétudes sur le fait que ces 23
transferts passent demain sur la route
et ce qu'il n'y a pas une piste à
étudier puisque Clément Moon a dit une
des lignes rouges c'est pas de report
moderne et on va pas arriver enfin la
situation dans laquelle ça a été très
bien écrit ou la SNCF va être
sous-traitante d'une entreprise privée
qui va venir sur le marché c'est quand
même quelque chose qui paraît absolument
incroyable est-ce qu'aujourd'hui s'il
n'y a pas de garantie qu'un de ces
trafics soit repris par du privé est-ce
que la SNCF ne peut pas continuer à le
gérer pour éviter que la nouvelle entité
ne devienne sous-traitante d'une
entreprise privée parce que ça pose
quand même question c'est à dire qu'on
détruit une entreprise publique
on demande de transférer des parts des
transferts des flux au privé comme le
privé ne va pas être en capacité ils
vont prendre les marchés mais ils auront
pas les moyens et c'est la SNCF qui va
sous-traiter donc ça interroge quand
même sur aussi sur la logique qui a
derrière cette procédure de
discontinuité
alors qu'il souhaite répondre
allez-y monsieur secrétaire général oui
alors quels moyens pour doubler la part
modale alors ça mélange un certain
nombre de choses parce que avec la
question de la discontinuité on a une
donnée nouvelle mais en 2020 la CGT
avait sorti un document qui s'appelait
ensemble pour le fret dans lequel on
faisait un ensemble de propositions il y
avait exactement 13 propositions et
notamment une reconquête phase et parce
que nous ne croyons absolument pas aux
objectifs qui sont jetés en l'air
doublement du trafic voilà ça nous
paraît absolument pas cohérent et donc
nous on souhaitait phase et puisqu'il y
a beaucoup de choses à remettre en place
avant de regagner un développement et
par exemple nous considérions que de
2021 à 2030 il fallait assurer la
reconstruction de de l'entreprise et
notamment avoir pour objectif de
regagner les trafics qui ont été perdus
en 2000 enfin depuis 2000 en parallèle
de cette reconstruction il fallait
lancer les travaux lourds un certain
nombre de travaux lourds sur
l'infrastructure notamment qui était
nécessaire ça nous permettait d'avoir un
une deuxième phase d'accélération dans
lequel grâce à la fin de ces travaux
lourds on pouvait espérer entre 2030 et
2040 avoir une phase de progression
massive des volumes et une phase de
consolidation pour les 10 dernières
années puisque là on rentrerait dans un
phénomène de de circuit
cercle vertueux je vais y arriver qui
qui nous permettrait normalement de de
parce qu'on a assuré des constructions
de volume massifs d'associer de nouveaux
trafic et de consolider cette ce
développement pour donner un seul
exemple quand on parle de doublement du
trafic aujourd'hui pas pour illustrer la
part de marché du ferroviaire dans les
produits métalliques c'est à peu près
40%. imagine-t-on qu'on va passer à 80%
c'est à dire qu'on va devenir
pratiquement monopoliste sur les
produits benalliques ça nous paraît
totalement délirant donc nous nous
considérons que il faut regarder les
choses de manière précise un certain
nombre de de marchés doivent être
développés et les produits les produits
métalliques comme d'autres mais il faut
aussi par exemple trouver de nouveaux
marchés aujourd'hui on a l'exception du
Perpignan agi on ne fait pratiquement
plus de primeurs et nous ne faisons plus
de primeurs pourquoi parce que nous ne
fabriquons plus de wagons enfin en tout
cas nous n'achetons plus de wagon
réfrigéré parce que les marchés
d'intérêt national ont été beaucoup
délocalisés et ne sont pas embranchés
faire parce que il n'y a pas de
stratégie réelle de liaison avec les
ports
fluo maritimes et les ports maritimes
pour transporter les importations ou
exportations de produits alimentaires et
donc tout ça ça nécessite une
implication forte de l'État et et un peu
de temps implication forte de l'État
j'y viendrai sur la discontinuité nous
nous considérons qu'on ne peut pas
développer ce type de marché nouveau
alors je parle des produits alimentaires
mais on en a par exemple les déchets qui
ne sont pas du tout aujourd'hui
transporté par la SNCF le bois où il y a
pratiquement plus de transport par la
SNCF enfin il y a un certain nombre
enfin voilà ferroviaire il y a un
certain nombre de secteurs dans lequel
il est il est nécessaire de de créer de
créer l'activité en fait et donc ça ça
ne se fera pas simplement par les
incantations et on a un petit peu
l'impression d'avoir les sorciers qui
font la danse de la pluie alors parfois
il pleut quand les sorciers font la
danse de la pluie et donc parfois il y a
un train qui est créé par l'opération du
marché mais quand même la plupart du
temps c'est plutôt la désagrégation de
du système ferroviaire auquel on assiste
pour développer le système ferroviaire
si on prend l'exemple du Perpignan
Rungis et de ses 12 millions de
subventions par an pourquoi il faut 12
millions de subventions par an parce que
vous avez un train d'abord donc il va
falloir suivre assurer l'investissement
en matériel roulant et notamment dans
les wagons sur une très petite quantité
de de charges parce que le Perpignan
Rungis c'est un transambolique mais
c'est quand même pas dans la fraction
des enfin c'est une toute petite
fraction de de des produits alimentaires
français et ensuite parce que vous avez
pas de boucle logistique vous faites un
aller-retour et au retour vous êtes à
vide et donc forcément ça multiplie les
les coûts de ce train si vous voulez
créer une boucle logistique aujourd'hui
il faut vous assurer d'obtenir tous les
marchés alors déjà il faut vous assurer
des infrastructures comme j'ai dit
précédemment mais il faut vous assurer
que tous les marchés
restent à la même entreprise et donc si
vous faites du Perpignan Rungis pour
monter des primeurs à Rungis ensuite à
Rungis vous récupérez des bananes qui
viennent du Havre et que vous les amener
à Lille que du de l'île vous récupérez
des patates que vous descendez à Lyon
qu'à Lyon vous récupérez les fruits de
de la Drôme et que vous les ramenez par
exemple à Perpignan vous avez fait votre
boucle et votre train il est plein en
permanence et donc là il est rentable
c'est ça la politique de volume et c'est
ça qui faisait la force de la SNCF sauf
que ça si vous perdez l'un un seul des
des des trafics cités toute votre boucle
tombe par terre et donc personne n'ose
se lancer dans ce style d'exploitation
il y a un paradoxe aujourd'hui on ne
créera pas de nouveaux marchés dans les
conditions actuelles et donc c'est pour
ça que nous nous défendons le fait que
on pourrait avoir une discontinuité
alternative une discontin continuité
dans laquelle nous proposons de recréer
un service de fret dans la SA SNCF
voyageur et que ce service de fret se
charge de tous les éléments à caractère
stratégique national puisque la règle de
la concurrence est une règle absolue
sauf parce qu'il y a plein d'exception
dans les règles européennes sauf quand
un état considère que dans il y a des
éléments stratégiques qui qui lui impose
d'exclure ces éléments là donc dans ces
éléments stratégiques nous proposons d'y
mettre les éléments régaliens les
transports de l'armée les transports
nucléaire les éléments sécuritaires les
transports de les transports
exceptionnels et les transports
chimiques les marchés à créer tous ces
éléments nouveaux sur lequel il faut
investir massivement peut-être éponger
un peu les plâtres donc je les ai cités
et puis également le wagon isolé parce
que le wagon isolé ne repartira pas
aujourd'hui le wagon isoler n'existe
plus ce qu'on appelle wagon isolé c'est
déjà plus du wagon isolé comme on le
faisait il y a 20 ans il y a 20 ans on
allait chercher un wagon dans une
entreprise maintenant c'est des coupons
de wagons et s'il y a pas un certain
nombre de coupons de wagons prêts
établi par les entreprises on ne va pas
aller chercher parce que ça permet de
limiter justement le le nombre de
d'opérations de de manœuvres et de
choses comme ça évidemment que plus vous
augmentez le coupon nécessaire plus vous
réduisez la taille des entreprises qui
sont capables de fournir ça donc si vous
voulez un développement massif du du
transport ferroviaire il faut aller
chercher les wagons des PME et donc il
faut construire des embranchements
particuliers il faut construire une
organisation de production dans lequel y
compris un wagon peut être intégré dans
un système efficace ça n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui donc on propose aussi
puisque ça ne marche pas dans le cadre
du marché de le mettre dans ces éléments
de caractère stratégiques nationales et
de le sortir de de la concurrence
actuelle et après bon voilà il y a un
certain nombre de d'autres sujets
d'autres propositions qu'on fait sur les
13 je vous les détails pas parce que
c'est ce serait un peu trop loin sur la
denrée alimentaire je suis revenu les
questions environnementales
oui les questions environnementales pour
nous elles sont importantes parce que
comme ça a été dit le le train est un
est un mode d'un mode doux du point de
vue des transports nous considérons que
il n'y a pas de politique de report
modal aujourd'hui de l'État il y a une
politique de subvention une politique de
subvention qui vient en concurrence
d'une logique de transport gratuit qui a
été établie dans le mode routier et
malheureusement on est obligé de
constater qu'à chaque fois que le
ferroviaire obtient des subventions il
est rare que le routier n'obtiennent pas
derrière des
des aides au moins équivalentes sur
la garantie que la discontinuité
satisfait la commission évidemment on ne
peut pas le garantir et on se pose
énormément de questions sur le fait que
la commissaire étant c'est pas
démissionnaire mais en disponibilité
visant un autre poste aujourd'hui quid
de ses engagements à elle est-ce que
c'était des engagements personnels
est-ce que c'était des engagements
collectifs comme nous n'avons pas été
associés aux discussions nous serions
bien mal de de le dire mais on peut
quand même imaginer qu'en fonction du
nouveau ou de la nouvelle commissaire il
pourrait y avoir un regard différent et
peut-être même plus dur sur sur le
dossier
se débarrasser du sparada du fret c'est
une évidence et c'est une évidence pour
tout le monde aujourd'hui l'activité de
fret par sa taille est anecdotique dans
le groupe SNCF et donc c'est quelque
chose qui existe mais voilà c'est pas
forcément rechercher et désiré c'est pas
le cas des cheminots évidemment qui pour
pour qui c'est une activité extrêmement
symbolique extrêmement importante et qui
pourrait redevenir importante y compris
économiquement et se débarrasser du
sparadrap au niveau gouvernemental c'est
aussi une évidence parce que comme je le
disais le marché il est extrêmement
difficile la question qu'on peut se
poser c'est par rapport au déficit que
j'annonçais des compagnies privées parce
que finalement on se dit pas aussi
qu'affaiblit un peu l'entreprise
principale ça permettrait d'éviter que
l'ensemble du château de cartes se casse
la figure ce sont des spéculations mais
on est en droit de de se poser ces
questions là l'opération de
privatisation oui c'est une opération de
privatisation puisque la discontinuité
il ne s'agit pas de simplement de
changer le nom ou de ou de modifier les
actifs on nous a explicitement ni qu'il
fallait changer la nature du capital et
que donc il faudrait probablement une
entrée
partielle ou majoritaire on sait pas
précisément
au capital on nous a garantis que ce
serait du capital public donc nous
imaginons mais là encore c'est de la
de l'hypothèse de la déduction que ça
pourrait être la Caisse des Dépôts y
consignations des choses comme ça parce
que ce sont des scénarios qui sont
courus recourus chauffés et réchauffés
et pour nous ce sont les étapes de
privatisation supplémentaire et je
laisse sur les travaux de nuit mon
camarade répondant
juste en 30 secondes
sur les travaux de régénération bon bah
de toute façon c'est pratiquement 100%
de sous-traitance SNCF réseau fait plus
aucun travaux de régénération toutes les
sous-traités à des grands groupes comme
enfin des filiales de grands groupes
comme Bouygues et Fages Vinci les mêmes
qui sont propriétaires des concessions
autoroutières
sur la maintenance et la volonté de
faire de deux sociétés typiquement il
faut savoir que au 1er janvier 2020 il y
a la constitution de la SAS Frat SNCF et
puis on prend également environ 500
cheminots voilà de la direction du
matériel voilà qui est en charge de la
maintenance du matériel ferroviaire et
puis on les transfère de façon
obligatoire également en fait dans la
SAS Frat SNCF voilà
maintenant ce qui est proposé en
discontinuité c'est que bah c'est même
500 salariés qui ont déjà été transférés
il y a trois ans en fait dans SAS fret
bah il soit de nouveau retransférés dans
une autre entité voilà qui s'occuperait
uniquement de la maintenance en fait du
transport ferroviaire de marchandise
mais qui pourrait prester en tout cas
qui pourrait offrir des prestations de
maintenance aux opérateurs privés voilà
puisque les opérateurs privés en sont un
peu dépourvu de ce savoir-faire cette
qualité là donc là c'est pour favoriser
en fait finalement le marché privé on
oblige globalement alors c'est pas dans
la cadre de la procédure de continuité
de ce qu'on nous a dit ça revêt d'un
choix stratégique de l'entreprise
mais ce n'est pas une obligation liée à
la procédure du discontinuité
et puis oui peut-être pour la précision
alors on regardera mais c'est sncfc 10
ou SNCF C11 j'ai plus en tête qui
devient en fait et SNCF voilà on
pourrait répondre à votre interrogation
Monsieur le Secrétaire général Julien
trocaze et puis ensuite monsieur
Charrière
des demandes de
l'ordre des demandes de prise de parole
excusez-moi non non
alors on va on va on va compléter
oui évidemment le ferroviaire dans une
crise écologique est incontournable
indispensable
sur pour compléter ce qu'a dit Laurent
brun enfin nous on pense aussi sur
aujourd'hui il y a des décisions qui
sont prises et qui sont irréversibles ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on a une crise
écologique et on enlève des voix
aujourd'hui il y a des embranchements
particuliers qui sont enlevés qui sont
supprimés et ce n'est pas possible
aujourd'hui dans un pays comme le nôtre
on enlève deux voix et quand on enlève
des voies sur qu'on les supprime pour
faire des fins pour faire des zones
industrielles ou des choses comme ça et
quand on dit une mesure urgente par
exemple et ça c'est quelque chose qui
est réversible parce que quand on a
enlevé des voix et qu'on a mis des
bâtiments à la place c'est compliqué de
les remettre et par exemple une mesure
ça serait de dire on fait on arrête et
on fait un état des lieux quand même de
l'existant aussi et on pense qu'il faut
il y a des mesures fortes qui peuvent
déjà se dire qu'est-ce qui existe sur
alors pour compléter sur le sparadrap
allez un peu plus loin on est sur une
séquence où évidemment
la privatisation la liquidation de frais
de SNCF arrange plutôt bien la Direction
SNCF parce qu'elle a elle continue aussi
au niveau du thé vert enfin Laurent
aussi et le ferroviaire il y a pas que
le fret et au niveau de tes verts ou des
SNCF Voyages et même d'intercité on
vient d'avoir un dossier on a aussi cet
accélération de démantèlement enfin de
tout finaliser de tout privatiser et on
a nous ce qu'on dit syndicalement une
nouvelle Contre Réforme des ferroviaire
qui est en train de revenir après 2018
avec application 2020 on a une nouvelle
étape et on a toutes les toutes les SA
ou les SAS qui qui vont devenir des
filiales qu'on appelle de rando donc en
gros là dessus pour pour la Direction
SNCF et le patron enfin les planètes
sont plutôt alignées donc on y voit on y
voit quelque chose là dedans sur
et ça fait lien entre le syndrome France
Télécom sur le deal que personne entre
Clément Beaune et la commissaire
européenne qui qui est en cours de
partir la fin vous comprenez qui donc
évidemment les cheminots les cheminots
ça a été dit c'est symbolique ça fait le
lien avec France Télécom je sais pas si
vous en connaissez mais ça a été un
choix professionnel des cheminots des
cheminotes qu'on travaillait pour fêter
SNCF donc c'est un choix dans une
carrière d'aller dans cette activité là
et pas rester dans le voyageur vous
pendant le covid ce sont c'était les
premiers de cordée alors les premiers de
cordée les cheminots les cheminots dans
les clips on les voyait pas trop mais
c'était eux les collègues du frais de
ferroviaire ils étaient les premiers
cordée parce qu'il y avait les les
denrées importantes qu'il fallait faire
et eux donc ils s'intéressent quand même
aux choses ils sont en train de
comprendre qu'il y a un deal qui a été
fait avec une commissaire européenne
qu'on a ni trace d'inécrit et qu'elle
est en train de partir et qu'on demande
juste de dire mais est-ce qu'on peut
avoir une preuve je sais que vous enfin
moi j'écoutais tout à l'heure à la
première ministre il y a eu des
questions là-dessus il y a personne même
au plus haut niveau du gouvernement qui
a une trace écrite et la Direction SNCF
qui est notre employeur et nous on y
pose on parle d'employeur parce que
l'employeur il a une obligation de
préservation de la santé morale et
physique des salariés on parle pas de
management là on parle d'employeurs et
quand on a la semaine dernière on voit
la direction de l'entreprise et on
demande on dit bah est-ce que vous
pouvez au moins avoir le directeur du
cabinet ce qui nous répandre la
direction scène c'est nous on a rien vu
et on a rien vu ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui et ça ça fait le lien
avec la question sur le syndrome France
Télécom effectivement on en profite
parce qu'on est des représentants et
représentants du personnel d'alerter
là-dessus en disant évidemment ce manque
d'avenir cette absence cette trahison en
fait se dire entre on est en train de
nous expliquer parce que la politique de
la Direction SNCF aujourd'hui c'est dire
l'année prochaine en 2024 il va falloir
faire des efforts parce qu'il va falloir
être productif pour la prochaine filiale
pour les prochaines sociétés et on a des
chimio des cheminottes aujourd'hui qui
n'ont aucune réponse qui n'a aucune
perspective donc oui effectivement on
est sur une situation qu'on caractérise
de syndrome France Télécom qui est
évidemment très présente et prenante il
manquerait juste de la responsabilité et
juste cette question de le deal qui a
été fait avec l'Europe et bah de le dire
de l'écrire et pas juste rester du
courrier de Clément Beaune qui a écrit à
Jean-Pierre pharadou pour la feuille de
route suite à la table ronde qu'on avait
eu le 22 mai
merci monsieur le Président donc
simplement et rapidement sur la question
du report modal et des possibilités qui
pourraient être mises en oeuvre pour
développer le frais de ferroviaire la
star d'autres pays puisque il s'agit pas
d'inventer des choses qui qui
fonctionnent à l'extérieur et de
regarder ce qui se passe par exemple en
Pologne en Allemagne où on est aux
environs de 20% de par modèle
ferroviaire aux environs de 30% pour la
Suède et l'Autriche et plus de 33% pour
la Suisse et on constate qu'en France
que les sillons utilisés par le frais de
ferroviaire c'est juste sur quelques
axes c'est pas sur l'ensemble des axes
et c'est un problème en fait
d'infrastructure avec pas suffisamment
de d'itinéraires fiable et une
saturation des nœuds ferroviaires donc
ce qu'on fait nos voisins c'est
simplement enfin simplement avoir des
investissements plus importants pour
maintenir et développer le réseau des
subventions de fonctionnement et
également avoir une incitation en report
modal et bien souvent c'est
l'interdiction de circuler pour les
poids lourds sur certains moments ou sur
certains axes et des péages routiers et
je laisse compléter Lionel sur la suite
merci
oui donc rapidement
sur les assurances que nous avons de la
Commission européenne donc non
actuellement on n'a aucune assurance de
la Commission européenne vous avez
auditionné mises et transports monsieur
Beaune on a suivi on a suivi en direct
cette audition monsieur bonady il me
semble qu'il a eu si réunion 6 réunions
vérifiables dans son agenda avec
Margaret westiger à cette heure-ci ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que ce qu'on sait
c'est juste que Monsieur Beaune veut
nous faire entendre donc on a aucune
assurance de la Commission européenne ce
qu'on sait de la commissaire madame
westiger c'est que elle a eu des
réunions avec des députés européennes et
à cette heure-ci elle elle dit que elle
n'a absolument rien demandé au
gouvernement et que
et que le calendrier n'est pas n'est pas
aussi rapide que que ce que le
gouvernement et ce que la direction
devrait SNCF et du groupe veut nous le
faire entendre ensuite pour répondre à
Monsieur le Député est-ce qu'on en a
parlé succinctement monsieur Gomet sur
la nouvelle entreprise la nouvelle
entité new em qui s'appelle nouvelle
entreprise maintenant donc effectivement
les agents ont des agents de Fredd SNCF
ont de quoi être très en colère de cette
situation mais les agents de maintenant
ce qui s'appelait technique Fred dans le
temps qui ont été réintégrés intégrés à
la sastreet en 2020 eux n'ont rien
vraiment vraiment rien demandé à qui que
ce soit et eux ont la double peine ils
ont déjà intégré la SAS prête en 2020 et
maintenant eux ils sont pour rien et on
applique cette discontinuité également à
ces agents là donc voilà c'est c'est la
double peine pour eux donc c'est tout
merci monsieur le Président peut-être
plusieurs éléments de réponse je vais
faire peut-être premier paquet autour de
autour des enjeux des enjeux écologiques
alors oui effectivement on parlait tout
à l'heure de conviction je pense que le
ferroviaire aujourd'hui l'urgence
climatique joue clairement pour lui
pourquoi parce que le ferroviaire il a
des atouts indéniable alors le premier
il était rappelé c'est un enjeu
aujourd'hui de il est faiblement il
aimait peu de CO2 mais au-delà de ça il
y a des atouts qui vont rester parce que
on voit aujourd'hui d'autres modes de
transport sont en train de se
transformer des nouvelles technologies
qui se mettent en eux voilà l'hydrogène
l'électricité par exemple mais au-delà
de ça le ferrovert gardera des atouts
indéniable aussi d'un point de vue par
lampe énergétique c'est-à-dire la
physique joue pour le ferrovert
aujourd'hui le contact rail roux sur un
rail on a besoin de très peu d'énergie
en fait pour déplacer un coup à
ferrovert par rapport à d'autres modes
de transport on gardera au-delà des
débat sur le fret par exemple des enjeux
aussi sur le masque transit pour faire
de la décongestion des grandes villes
enfin voilà donc le ferroviaire
effectivement dans ce moment
atomécologique il a des atouts certains
pour autant aujourd'hui si on veut le
développer peut-être 4 points déjà il
faut un réseau qui soit performant et là
ça vous renvoie effectivement la
question des investissements du réseau
qui ont été insuffisamment voilà on va
pas on pourra en parler à ce longuement
sur le désengagement de l'État qu'on
avait vu qu'on a vu quand même au fil du
temps dans notre pays qui a conduit
quand même à ce qu'on prenne un retard
comme assez important quand on voit
aujourd'hui on va dire de fret on est on
a quand même beaucoup de difficultés à
avoir des itinéraires dédiés au fret ce
qui est pas le cas par exemple de pays
comme l'Allemagne on a des problèmes de
décongestion des grands neufs
ferroviaires on a encore des trains de
fret aujourd'hui qui traversent des
grandes gares par exemple Lille Lyon
voilà ce qu'on a plus dans d'autres pays
étrangers on a un sujet aussi sur des
investissements par exemple on va dire
de signalisation sur le rTMS donc pour
pouvoir effectivement pouvoir plus de
trains qui circulent augmenter les flux
donc toutes ces questions là il y a
effectivement le premier volet qui a
volé d'investissement qui aujourd'hui
n'est pas suffisant pour pouvoir
effectivement répondre aux enjeux
deuxième deuxième élément
c'est la question des territoires on en
parlait tout à l'heure on voit
qu'effectivement d'autres pays qui ont
été cités en exemple il y a des
politiques qui sont beaucoup plus on a
100 de gravité qui est quand même
beaucoup plus plus proche des
territoires et on voit qu'effectivement
les politiques publiques je prends par
exemple l'exemple de la Suisse elle se
dessine elle se décide au niveau
territorial en associant pas mal
d'acteurs et on voit aujourd'hui que en
France on a un certain nombre
d'initiatives qu'on peut juger comme
intéressantes ou notamment on voit des
contrats d'investissement qui associent
l'État les régions mais aussi les
chargeurs tout simplement comme ça ça
prémunit un petit peu le risque quand
vous avez pardon je prends l'exemple de
Carrier ou de céréaliers on doit rénover
des voies de service pour pouvoir venir
desservir par exemple un silo ou une
carrière effectivement bah une fois que
l'industriel s'est engagé sur des
investissements comme sur un temps assez
long avec une aide de la région une aide
de l'État on voit qu'effectivement
d'ailleurs il est peut-être moins enclin
à faire du report modal parce qu'il a
aussi des investissements qui va falloir
qui rentabilise voilà et ça c'est des
éléments sur lesquels aussi en France on
est peut-être plus plus en retard en
tout cas nous ce qu'on voit et on l'a
dit tout à l'heure dans le sérieux de la
discontinuité il y a un risque aussi de
dégrader ce maillage territorial déjà
aujourd'hui quand vous faites un peu la
vision territoriale de fret SN en France
et même du transport on voit que le
centre circule plus partout une partie
du territoire aujourd'hui qui est plus
du tout desservie notamment l'ouest de
la France c'est une réalité donc si on
veut un manque des trains il y a un
risque avec cette danse qui ont
disponibilité c'est que le modèle
économique qu'on a aujourd'hui et vous
le situez tout à l'heure monsieur le
Président en rappelant effectivement que
on avait une mob qui était positive en
2022 2021 mais également un cash fluide
qui était à l'équilibre c'est à dire pas
de dette ce qui permettait effectivement
de financer les investissements et qui
était basé un modèle actuel qui était
basé comme sur un triptyque qui était
d'un côté un développement du trafic
mais un développement des trafics
conjugué entre d'un côté des trafics du
combiné et des trafics de wagons isolés
voilà de gestion capacitaire et ce
modèle là aujourd'hui on vient quand
même le bousculer et qui permettait
quand même d'ici 2030 en tout cas
quelques objectifs étaient posés d'avoir
une stabilité stabilité si on avait pour
le coup aussi un maintien des
subventions publiques qui est quand même
effectivement un peu l'alpha et l'oméga
et une stabilité des effectifs de
production voilà ce qui était quand même
un peu quelque chose qui était posé
aujourd'hui on voit que la discontinité
de bousculer ce modèle et si on zoom un
peu au niveau du territoire pour nous
elle présente un risque c'est quand
demain vous allez vous retrouver à
devoir un peu optimiser on vous impose
ultime de productivité tels que la
modélisation est faite là pour les pour
les pour les deux nouvelles filiales il
y a un risque que vous renoncez à
certains trafics qui sont compliqués à
capter qui sont peu rentables au profit
de trafic plus facile au repérer et ça
c'est un risque qu'on a accentue encore
à notre sens cette fracture territoriale
qui est déjà là et il suffit de regarder
au jus aujourd'hui la carte des desserts
on s'aperçoit que la France n'est pas
irriguée de la même manière ça c'est une
question qui est essentielle troisième
élément bien évidemment je l'évoquais à
travers le modèle économique c'est avoir
un opérateur qui robuste et nous côté
CFDT on considère qu'une entreprise pour
qu'elle se porte bien il faut à la fois
qu'il conjugue des enjeux économiques et
des enjeux sociaux voilà pour répondre
un peu à la question tout à l'heure du
rapporteur de monsieur le rapporteur sur
la partie cadre social aujourd'hui on
vous reverra au dossier qui avait été
transmis aux élus CSL 29 mai ou
clairement la continuité du cadre social
n'est pas assurée puisque dans ce
dossier l'entreprise a clairement
indiqué qu'il y avait maintien du statut
du régime spécial de retraite et de
prévoyance et que d'autres éléments du
cadre social notamment l'organisation du
travail les contours des métiers
seraient adaptés et que pour le reste
des grands éléments je dirais fondateurs
du cadre social c'était renvoyer une
négociation la fin d'année donc ça c'est
un pronostic c'est à dire que si on veut
un mot aussi assurer du type de
développement il faut une entreprise qui
se porte bien et avec des gens qui ont
envie de travailler et qui ont
effectivement qui ont envie de
travailler pour l'activité du frais de
ferroviaire
ça c'est un petit peu par rapport à la
question qui était posée sur la
Commission européenne alors non la
réponse sur la même réponse que nos
collègues nous n'avons pas à ce stade
d'engagement ou de en tout cas de prise
de position écrite qui nous dirait qu'il
confirme que ces scénarios validé un
point de vue juridique et par rapport
effectivement à votre marque sur le
sparada du fret nous nous ce qu'on
s'interroge peut-être juste le rappeler
à hauteur d'agent à hauteur d'agent tout
ce qu'on échange les arguments
juridiques qu'on a pu peut-être invoquer
aujourd'hui tout ça ça ressemble
peut-être un petit peu à un espèce de
grand tour de magie c'est un tour de ça
se passe vu des gens c'est à dire les
gens ne comprennent pas comment on a un
seul coup on se transforme face à ces
discontinuité déjà le mot c'est un mot
qu'on emploie pas souvent ouais c'est un
mot et les gens au début n'avaient pas
compris ce que ça voulait dire d'une
discontinuité d'économique on arrive à
une discontinuité d'activité on a une
discontinuité de marque enfin voilà
c'est voilà ce mot il emporte
effectivement beaucoup de signification
et je les ai tout à l'heure on voit
qu'il y a eu une phase qui est une phase
de stupéfaction qui laisse aujourd'hui
une place de colère est-ce que nous
remonte le corset aujourd'hui c'est que
cette décision des discontinuité elle
est injuste et elle est injustifiée ah
et là dedans effectivement on n'est pas
pour rentrer dans des espèces de
théories du complot je ne sais quoi mais
ce qu'on peut nous interroger comme
légitimement c'est qu'on a détaillé tout
à l'heure la saison 1 qui avait lu en
2018 là on est dans la saison 2 on peut
déjà s'interroger si en fait on n'est
pas en train de préfigurer la saison 3
et la saison 3 c'est quoi c'est un
glissement finalement de ces deux
filiales qui vont pas vivre très
longtemps pour aller sur une stratégie
qui a une stratégie de rail logistique
Europe c'est à dire à un moment que les
trains reviennent n'ont pas à
l'opérateur public mais à des filiales
type 4 traîne voilà et ça c'est une
question quand même que légitimement
aujourd'hui côté CVT on se pose
merci beaucoup à toutes et à tous on a
passé deux bonnes heures ensemble et
commission d'enquête a déjà effectué
7h15 de d'audition aujourd'hui je
voulais vraiment vous remercier pour la
qualité et le respect des échanges qu'on
a eu ainsi que les éléments que vous
avez exprimés à la fois factuel et les
éléments d'opinion donc nous on va
poursuivre nos travaux soyez certains en
tout cas pour même s'il y a des visions
très différentes qui s'expriment dans la
commission je parle cette fois-ci au nom
des des députés présents et tous ne sont
pas mais au nom des députés présents
qu'il y a avec des visions différentes
un engagement et une conviction que le
frais de ferroviaire est une voie
d'avenir qui partagait par l'ensemble
des collègues qui sont ici présents quel
que soit leur sensibilité voilà bonne
soirée à vous